МУЗЫКАЛЬНАЯ ЗАСТАВКА Nürnchen Nürnchen. Das Podcast-Ufos. Runde mit Stefan Tietze. Ihr könnt die Schuhe anlassen. Stefan Tietze, ja, wolltest du sagen. Stefan Tietze und Florian Wild ist unser Name. Richtig. Und bis zu bei dir zu Hause ein, erst mal vielen Dank Annabelle an dieses fantastische Intro. Wow, tolles Intro, Annabelle und Johannes haben sich zusammengetan, um dieses Intro zu kreieren. Grossartig. Grossartig und Strauss hat auch mitgeholfen. War aber mit dabei. Den lassen wir aber unter den Teppich fallen. Ich war mal bei einer Hochzeit und dann hat der Vater, der Braut, hat dann ein Lied gespielt, das er geschrieben hat für die beiden, so im Sinne von so alles Gute euch beiden und so. Und er ist total Fan von klassischer Musik und hat dann, ich glaube auch ein Lied von Strauss genommen und dann eine neue Melodie dazu geschrieben, einen neuen Text dazu geschrieben. Sonst wird es ja immer kompliziert, ehrlich gesagt. Und hat dann halt gesagt, so ja, alles Gute, cool. Und dann hat er was gemacht, was ich in der Geschichte der Musik noch nie erlebt habe. Und zwar hat er eine Art Abspann gesungen am Ende des Liedes. Also er hat in der Melodie des Liedes gesungen, ja, Melodie von Richard Strauss, Text von mir und hat wirklich so einen Stich. Schnitt, Arrangement von Peter Hoze. Ja, Casting, hat wirklich so eine Art Abspann als Teil des Musiks. Ich finde das unfassbar. Ich sass da wirklich da und habe mich so umgeguckt und so, merkt ihr gerade, was hier gerade passiert? Sie hat ja Geschichte geschrieben. Und alle saßen nur da und hatten irgendwie Torte im Mund und so. Strunz betrunken. Strunz, die Leute verstehen nicht, was um sie rum passiert. Nee, geht man mit offenen Augen durch die Welt. Ja, Augen auf, Mund zu. Augen auf, ja, das haben viele auch nicht verstanden. Oder Augen auf, Mund auf, Ohren zu. Ohren neutral. Aber bist du jemand, wo du gerade meines, kommt rein, lass die Schuhe an, finde ich eine gute Einstellung eigentlich.
Weil, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon erwähnt, aber ich bin umgezogen und das natürlich auch, irgendwann stellt man sich halt schon die Frage so, was bin ich für ein Haushalt? Bin ich ein auf dem Teppich keine Schuhe bitte Haushalt, bin ich ein ihr könnt die Schuhe komplett anlassen, bin ich ein bitte barfuss mit diesen wie diesen, wie man in manchen Fabriken hat, diese Box vorne, wo man sich die so Überziehschuhe, Plastiktüte, Plastikschüchen rausholen kann, so eine Haarhaube. Ja, Holzschuhe. Bin ich diese Art Mensch oder was bin ich für ein Mensch? Haben wir jetzt entschieden für, macht einfach mal alles. Ja, ich fühle mich immer extrem unwohl mit Schuhen in einem Haus. Also bei uns war das halt normale Schuhe aus dem Haus und bis heute fühle ich mich immer extrem unwohl und schmutzig. Und ich denke immer, ich stehe gerade auf dem Teppich und bin gerade irgendwie über Kies gelaufen. Habt ihr eine Ahnung was mit diesem Kies? Aber Kies ist doch unglaublich sauber. Ja, aber wer da schon alles drüber gelaufen ist, was da kreucht und fleucht in diesem Kies. Das ist wirklich... Was in dem Teppich los ist, für Teppichtierchen. Nee, aber ich bin da wirklich kein Fan davon. Aber es ist ja oft so, dass man aufwächst mit gewissen Regeln und einfach denkt, das ist überall so. Und dann irgendwann ist man mal mit einem Freund zu Besuch und die haben irgendwie so quadratische Blätter unter den Tellern. So, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die heißen. Und dann schnittst du den Freund und dann schnittst du die und du hast es so im Mund, weil du nicht weißt, wer das ist, was man damit macht. Und man sitzt das erste Mal am Tisch und da sind diese Untersetzer und man guckt alle so an, so Was passiert damit? Was ist das? Was ist das? Wird da was eingerollt? Kommt dann noch was? Ich war bei einer Familie, wo man dann gebetet wurde kurz. Oh, das ist auch unangenehm. Und ich habe für bestimmt allen Menschen nicht geglaubt, dass es gerade ernsthaft gemeint ist, sondern das ist ein Scherzer. Du hast laut gedacht, geiler Gag, geiler Gag. Dann gab es eine Familie, wo immer leise gesprochen wurde. Also sehr leise gesprochen wurde, aber beim Tisch war immer so, also sobald man am Tisch saß, gab es so ein, kannst du mir kurz das Wasser reichen? So eine Stimmung. Guten Appetit. Danke. Und wie war es heute in der Schule? Also man hat gesprochen, weil es nicht verstanden hat. Es wurden Fragen gestellt, es wollte Konversation gemacht werden, aber es wollte nicht laut gesprochen werden. Das fand ich komisch, aber auch eine andere Regel. Das ist aber auch, glaube ich, so eine soziale Lawine, das kann man machen. Wenn einer anfängt, leise zu sprechen, sprechen alle anderen auch automatisch leise und man hört einfach nicht mehr auf und niemand weiß, warum, wie das mal angefangen hat. Aber wenn du einfach mal in einem Restaurant einfach mal anfängst, hey Leute, ich kann das Essen, oder? Also schön Atmosphäre. Das ist ja unsere Theorie im Ruheabteil, dass sich im Ruheabteil bis zur Endstation hochgeschaukelt hat, in dem Dezibelbereich, wo es dann schon schwierig wird. Aber es fängt ruhig an und dann fängt einer an zu telefonieren, dann fangen Leute an zu beschweren, dann fangen Leute an, lauter zu telefonieren, also es schaukelt sich so ein bisschen hoch und Endstation haben Westfalen ist dann im Prinzip nicht mehr zu unterscheiden zum Familienabteil. Ja, was ich jetzt häufiger zu etablieren versuche, ist klatschen. Ich bin ein großer Fan geworden. Wenn man in einer Endstation ist. Ich bin ein großer Fan geworden von klatschen. Generell. In sozialen Situationen, weil du kannst generell auch, ich klatsche auch privat immer mehr, merke ich tatsächlich, ich höre einen guten Song und ich klatsche einfach, ich finde es einfach respektvoll, es gehört sich einfach und ich finde es einfach toll in sozialen Situationen immer mehr Klatschen zu etablieren, weil es oft so ist, dass Menschen einfach mitgerissen werden und man sowas etablieren kann.
Zum Beispiel habe ich letztens einen Tanzkurs gemacht. Ich dachte mir, fuck it. Aber so standard? Ich dachte mir, warum nicht, ich mache einfach einen Tanzkurs und ich schaue mal einfach so, was so geht in der Welt des Tanzes. Ich habe ja, glaube ich, vor zehn Jahren. Ich kann nicht sagen, was da geht, seit Jahren nichts mehr. Da wird von rechts nach rechts nach links gewackelt und dann ist Jun. Ich habe vor zehn Jahren ja, glaube ich, mal einen Tanzkurs gemacht und dachte so, ich will einfach wieder up to date sein, will ein bisschen auffrischen. Und es stellt sich raus, Jive ist noch Jive. Jive ist immer noch the same. Das ist wie den alten Freund kennenlernen. Und es ist immer so, am Ende der Tanzstunde klatschen alle. So am Ende, wenn die Tanzlehrerin dann sagt, so bis nächste Woche und alle klatschen. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, wie weit kann ich das treiben? Weil Schritt eins, weil es gibt immer eine Pause in der Mitte der Tanzstunde. Ich dachte mir, okay, Schritt eins ist es, nicht nur am Ende der Stunde zu klatschen, sondern schon am Ende der ersten Hälfte zu klatschen. Das heißt, wenn sie sagt, okay, wir sehen uns gleich wieder nach der Pause und die Leute machen geschlossen mit, die machen einfach mit. Du kriegst es und irgendwann bei der zweiten Tanzstunde ist es normal, dass die Leute nach der ersten Hälfte klatschen. Jetzt kannst du, ich habe den am Anfang direkt. Am Anfang direkt, mein Ziel ist es, sie kommt in den Raum und die klatscht, ununterbrochen wird geklatscht. Mein Ziel ist es, nach jedem einzelnen Lied zu klatschen. Weil du hast ja immer so, du lernst einen neuen Tanzschritt, und dann macht man den einen Lied lang. Und mein Ziel ist es, immer wenn das Lied ausgeht, einfach zu klatschen und alle klatschen mit. Mein absolutes Ziel ist es, dass am Ende sie sagt, wir müssen gar nicht immer klatschen nach jedem Song, also ich will es so weit treiben. Das ist ganz unangenehm. Ja. Also eigentlich willst du es abschaffen. Eigentlich genau, eigentlich ist mein Ziel, dass es so absurd wird, dass sie gezwungen ist, es anzusprechen. Das ist mein Ziel, dass es jemand erwähnt oder mal so ein, warum klatschen wir ständig? Was mir gefällt, liegt ein bisschen im Kontext des Ortes auch. Ja. Ich glaube, dieses, fremde Menschen kommen zusammen, um ja ein bisschen was Intimes, Unangenehmes zu machen, ist wie so ein Kochkurs. Ja, genau. Wo ich mir vorstellen kann, ohne jemals beim Kochkurs gewesen zu sein, am Ende wird geklatscht. Ja, genau. Ich habe jetzt der Kontext. Man will seinen Partner dahin und irgendwie hat eine gute Zeit, man albert ein bisschen rum. Man hat dieses fremde, es sind fremde Menschen, aber die lernt man in so einem privaten, es wird sich gleich geduzt. Und jeder ist unsicher. Niemand weiß ganz genau, wie es funktioniert. Und man ist sehr leichter, wenn es vorbei ist. Es fällt viel ab. Und dann dieses auf den Boden gucken und klatschen, finde ich dann immer ganz gut. Aber auch Kontext des Ortes. Kontext des Ortes wäre aber auch wie Winken auf Schiffen. Das ist ein bisschen ein ähnliches Phänomen. Man winkt, also die Hemmschwelle zu winken ist auf dem Schiff gleich null. Es gibt keine, am Rhein zu stehen, da waren jetzt im Sommer waren da so coole Strandbars auch in der Corona-Zeit, wo mit viel Abstand und so, weil draußen war, haben da diese Restaurants so ein bisschen auch Plätze raus gebaut. Und da konnte man wunderbar sitzen und auf den Rhein gucken, auf so Liegestühlen und man muss nur mal, wenn so ein Schiff vorbeifährt, die Hand heben und das ganze Schiff ist ganz aufgeregt und alle haben die schnellen, die Ärmel in die Höhe und es wird gewunken, bis zu geht nicht mehr. Am liebsten mag ich die kleinen Kinder, die zu klein sind, um das Konzept Winken zu verstehen, und die Eltern nehmen dann die Hand des Kindes und winken für das Kind. Das ist für mich eine der absurdesten Szenen der Erziehung.
Kinder sind Marionetten.
Nein, einfach. Also das Kind lernt davon, also das ist ja wirklich so ein mit der Brechstange erziehen, jetzt bewegt dein Körper bitte auf diese Art. Und auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich, ist das so wichtig, einem Kind beizubringen, dass man winkt? Ich sehe, dass das Kind mich nicht grüßen will. Die Augen sagen, du bist mir egal, die Augen sagen wahrscheinlich, ich sehe dich noch nicht mal, weil mein Gehirn noch nicht so weit entwickelt ist. Nee, weil die Reling zu hoch ist. Man sieht nur so ein kleines Ärmchen über der Reling gezwungenermaßen winken.
Aber ganz toll finde ich, auf den deutschen Autobahnen zu fahren und dann ab und zu mal Mutter und Kind oder Vater und Kind oben auf der Brücke zu sehen, wie die dann winken. Und jedes Mal wicke ich zurück, weil es ist so einfach, diesen Menschen ein gutes Gefühl zu geben. Aber auch da natürlich der Klassiker der Lkw, wenn man auf der Brücke steht und dann so dieses Hupen macht und der Lkw dann auch hupt oder halt trötet. Ich weiß nicht, ist das nochmal was anderes? Oder ist der Klassiker, einfach so einen Stein zu nehmen und von der Brücke runterzuwerfen. Das ist auch wunderschön. Das ist auch schön, ja. Aber ist das was anderes als das Lenkradhupen? Ja, ich glaube... Also hat ein Lkw eine Lenkraddorfdrückhupe und dann nochmal diese Kordel? Ich glaube, dieses Runter heißt, dass man um diesen Panikgriff anfassen soll. Das ist eher so ein Safety-Ding. Auch ein wunderschönes Beispiel nonverbaler Kommunikation ist als Beifahrer, dem Fahrer zu signalisieren, dass es gerade ein bisschen rau zugeht, was auch nicht nötig ist. Wir fahren irgendwie ins Kino, wir haben eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Wir sind viel zu früh. Es gibt genug Parkplätze. Ich war zum heißen Reifen. 90 in der Innenstadt, irgendwie jede Kurve wird genommen wie, ja, halt irgendein Armin Seller, irgendein Raum, nee, Seller, Zellner, ähm, Niki Lauda meine ich.
Nee, Sender meinst du vielleicht, Ayr. Seller. Seller. Niki Lauda meine ich. Nee. Senna meinst du vielleicht? Ah, Niki, ja. Ayrton Senna gibt es ja. Genau. So. Ich bin immer schlecht. Aber Lauda ist auch gut. Also alle nicht schlecht. Okay. Wie Marco. Rosberg. Rosberg. Nico. Weiß ich. Egal. Also man fährt mit einem Affenzahn, sag ich mal. Sagen wir es mal so. Und um zu signalisieren, und vor allem es gibt ja zwei Stufen dieser Kommunikation, einmal rechte Hand dran an den Festhaltegriff des Beifahrers. Dann gefällt mir die linke Hand vorne abstützend. Aber was ich auch schon gesehen habe, ist, beide Hände halten fest am Griff, also beide Hände wirklich so wie an der Liane, wirklich wie an der Klippe. Und wenn der Fahrer es dann nicht checkt, dann muss man wirklich sagen, okay, gut, du lebst einfach für den Rennsport, dir ist es einfach alles egal. Aber also dieser Tanzkurs ist ja so ein bisschen, also du manipulierst den auf so eine unschöne Art. Ich versuche ihn an seine, ich versuche die gesellschaftliche Naht zu testen. Ich versuche zu testen, wie viel Druck muss man auf diese Situation ausüben, bis es bricht, weil das sind alle auf ihrem besten Verhalten, alle so schön, toll. Wie lange dauert es, bis jemand wirklich sagt, was ist denn diese scheissge Klatsche eigentlich ständig? Da will ich hin, dass jemand bricht.
Und cool ist ja, man kann sich immer die anderen angucken und schauen, wer bricht als erstes. Ja. Weil jeder Mensch hat diesen Instinkt, eine Gruppe Menschen zu sehen und zu wissen, wer ist der Schwächste. Das ist einfach noch aus unserer Wolfszeit, dass man einfach sieht, weil so ein Jaguar, der irgendwie sogar Zellen anrennt, der sieht ja auch, wer ist der Schwache und greift das Schwächste Glied der Gruppe an. Das ist ein Instinkt. Und so guckt man auch in so einen Kochkurs und weiß einfach, Mareike, du wirst nicht überleben, du wirst zurückgelassen. Wenn hier alle rennen, wirst du zurückgelassen. Du wirst gefressen. Du wirst einfach gefressen. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben ein paar Mal Yoga gemacht.
Und ...
Alleine oder als Kurs?
In einer Gruppe, in einem Online-Kurs. Meinst du, du kriegst es hin, dass nach jeder Figur alle klatschen? Ja, und nee, ich war schon so verwirrt, weil wir waren zu dritt. Also ich habe es gemacht mit jemandem im Raum und es war online. Und der hat es nur für uns beide gemacht. Also und dann gab es noch, remotely war dann noch jemand anderes zugeschaltet. So, es war so ein Dreier-Call und jetzt für uns drei halt gemacht im Prinzip, nicht viele Leute. Und am Ende wurde geklatscht, aber das war eine, weil ich nur mit einer anderen Person im Raum war, war sel seltsam, weil jeder kennt die Mindestanzahl für Applaus ist drei, weil man alleine klatscht. Stimmt, man klatscht nicht zu zweit. Ist doch kein Klatschen. Jetzt macht du mal mit. Okay, aber jetzt bei der dritten wird es auch schnell rhythmisch und dann wird es weird. und bei der dritten Person kriegt es dieses no-coole-Klatschgeräusch. Ah, okay. Und man war nur zu zweit im Raum, dann hat man schlecht abgemischt, dann dieses andere Klatschen von der anderen Person wahrgenommen. Zeitverzögert. Zeitverzögert, viel zu spät und das war nicht so schön. Was leider durch die Verzögerung so klingt, als würden alle exakt gleich klatschen, einfach so. Das klingt wie so ein ganz merkwürdiger Rhythmus. Nicht funktionieren. Gen schwierig, weil das war beim Urlaub und die Verbindung in diesem Hotel war nicht so toll.
Hies dann also, dass man in, also ich habe es auch zum ersten Mal gemacht und es war unglaublich anstrengend, weil man hat immer dann so eine Figur gemacht hat und in dem Moment war das Internet weg. Man steckte fest in dieser Figur, dann kam wieder irgendwann nach zehn Minuten, war die Verbindung wieder hergestellt und dann war die Yoga-Instruktorin, aber schon ganz woanders, hat dann so gesagt, jetzt leg die Hände ab. Aber man war gerade in so einer schwebenden Figur, wo man nowhere am Boden war mit den Händen und dann sah man aber nicht, weil das Bild doch so verschwommen war, was man jetzt machen soll.
Es war ein bisschen wie Twister, so und wer kippt zuerst um, war ein bisschen die Frage.
Und du machst so einen Liegestütz und sie sagt so und jetzt die Hände hoch und du Moment und du nimmst die Hände hoch und es funktioniert tatsächlich und du schwebst.
Yoga, ja, Yoga krasser Scheiss, aber tatsächlich gibt es so ein paar Sachen, die Krähe, ich hasse die Krähe, wo du wirklich quasi schwebst, wo ich auch kurz nach rechts gucken musste und gesagt habe, toll, du schwebst, also irgendwas ist so ganz grobisch gerade, wo man sich dann nach vorne lehnt und dann mit den Knien auf die Oberarme geht und dann schwebt man ja quasi und hält sich nur an den Füssen, an den Händen fest. Ja, ich habe ihn schon gesehen, ja. Also das sieht unnatürlich auch auf eine Art.
Er hat mir geholfen.
Also ich hätte dann die ganzen Tage, wo ich Yoga gemacht habe, mein sehr gutes Körpergefühl. Ich habe mich oft über Yoga lustig gemacht und muss einiges zurücknehmen. Also sorry. Gibt es sonst noch was, worüber du dich lustig gemacht hast, was du zurücknehmen? Tanzkurse, aber bin noch nicht bereit, das zurückzunehmen. Okay. Aber ich habe auch selber überlegt, weil ich tanze gern. Also ich kann nicht gut tanzen, aber ich mag Musik sehr gern und tanze sehr gern und ich hätte wahnsinnig Bock mal, also so eine, in einem Fitnessstudio zum Beispiel so einen Tanzkurs, so Hip-Hop oder sowas, das machen, wo man beim Ball auch irgendwie schwitzt und so, weil ich glaube, weil ich kann, also Ausdauersport nicht gut, aber ich glaube, wenn das so Musik ist, ja, bei Summa machst du halt Reggaeton für eine Stunde.
Das will ich nicht ertragen.
Nee, aber jetzt so, eigentlich wäre so Musical-Tanz hätte ich mega Bock, so eine Choreo, wo irgendwie dann so sechs Leute in einem Raum dann wirklich so tanzen und man wirft sich so zu. You can stop the beat, there is no one began and one done. Aber mein Problem ist folgendes an diesem Einzeltanz-Kurs-Ding, weil natürlich will man auch mal auf dem Tanz-Dancefloor dominieren. Ja, du willst auch einfach mal der Coole auf dem Dancefloor sein. Meiner Erfahrung nach sind aber in der Regel die Leute, die so tanzen, dass man ihnen ansieht, dass die wirklich tanzen können, dass sie tanzen gelernt haben, eher nicht cool. Also verstehst du, wenn du irgendwie mit Freunden tanzen gehst und alle haben irgendwie eine gute Laune und tanzen und einer haut halt die krassen Moves raus, irgendwie dann irgendwie Shuffle, Robot, denke ich mir immer so, das ist zu viel. Ja, nee, weil, was ich die ganze Zeit denken muss dann ist, wie lange hast du dieses YouTube-Video gekostet?
Ja.
Weil, also man ... Was ich die ganze Zeit denken muss dann ist, wie lange hast du dieses YouTube-Video gekonnt? Es ist ja früher, als YouTube noch nicht so geschafft hat irgendwie, und so hat man sich gefragt, krass geil, der war bestimmt oft feiern, cooler Typ, der war oft mit Freunden aus, um diese Skills zu entwickeln. Mittlerweile denke ich mir, wie viele einsame Stunden vor dem Spiegel hast du verbracht, um diesen Tanzen. Und vor allem, wenn du gelernt tanzen kannst, dann hast du ja nur eine limitierte Anzahl an Moves, sag ich mal. Das heißt, man kommt relativ schnell an sein Limit, weil du kannst ja nicht zwei Stunden lang eine Tanzroutine für zwei Stunden können. Du hast dann halt so drei Moves, wenn du halt so Anfänger bist, und die rotierst du. Und das wirkt total albern, wenn du nur diesen einen Shuffle-Move hast und den den ganzen Arm machst. Deswegen will ich eigentlich gut tanzen können, aber so, dass Leute denken, ich bin ein natürlich talentierter Tänzer, ohne dass ich es gelernt habe. Das ist eigentlich das, wo ich hin will. Wollen wir beide in einen Tanzkurs gehen? Ich will aber, dass niemand weiss, dass wir in diesem Tanzkurs sind. Damit, falls wir dann mal irgendwie bei der Live-Show dann irgendwie kommt, plötzlich ist Musik an und wir tanzen. Und wir beide können unglaublich gut tanzen. Das sind ja gute Tänzer, aber die sehen nicht so aus, als hätten sie es gelernt. Ja. Weil das ist ja eigentlich die Kunst. Okay, aber dann machen wir das und sagen es einfach jetzt niemandem. Ja, okay, das finde ich eine gute Idee. Ja, weil das finde ich schon schön, weil sonst zusammen irgendwie, das ist, glaube ich, ein guter Sport für mich. Das istnsinnig anstrengend, total gut für den Körper, man nimmt glaube ich wahnsinnig gut ab, baust irgendwie Muskeln auf, Stabilisatoren, Quark, weiß ich nicht was, und du hast halt irgendwie Musik, wo man sich gerne so bewegt. Ja, ich weiss noch nicht, ich habe halt Angst, dass meine unbedarfte leidenschaftliche Verbindung zum Tanz dadurch aufgelöst wird, weil ich bin sehr leidenschaftlicher, spontaner Tänzer, also auf dem Tanzbrett, Dancefloor, kann es auch mal wild hergehen. Und ich glaube, mir hilft gerade das, also ich glaube, meine Unbeholfenheit kann ich zu einer Tugend machen, dass ich nicht weiss, was ich machen soll und mir denke, es ist scheiss egal, ich sehe eh bescheuert aus und dann loslassen kann. Wohingegen, wenn ich so ein paar Moves hätte, würde ich mich, glaube ich, in denen eher gefangen fühlen. Ja, es ist fast, du gibst deine Freiheit ein bisschen auf. Dann gibst du deine Freiheit auf. So, es ist dann so. Ironischerweise. Ich wollte mal unbedingt diesen, wo es aussieht, ob man läuft, aber man ist auf der Stelle. Weißt du, wo man rennt? Und man denkt sich, wo will er hin? Man rennt, aber muss er schon. Aber weisst du welchen tanzt du dich meinst? Ich weiss welchen du meinst. Ich kann den nicht gut. Warte. Also so ein bisschen so. Zudem. Ja genau, und so. Man rennt auf die Hände, das ist so ein bisschen wie Kraulen, ne? Also als würdest du schwimmen, als würdest du kraulen. Man sieht selten, sieht man sich ja beim Tanzen, das ist ja mein Problem. Deswegen verstehe ich ja das Prinzip, grosser Spiegel bei Tanzstudios total. Hast du ab dir da auch so einen grossen Spiegel, wo du tanzt?
Ja, was ultra stressig ist, weil du halt immer spiegelverkehrt denken musst, weil das heisst immer linker Fuss und man denkt, das ist aber der rechte oder nicht, aber dann checkst du es nicht. Keine Ahnung, ich finde es schwierig, aber es ist eh schwer, Oberkörper und Unterkörper zu synchronisieren, dass es gut aussieht. Es gibt ja auch diese Riverdance, die ich eigentlich ganz konsequent finde, wo der Oberkörper einfach nichts macht, wo er einfach sagt, wir haben uns dazu entschieden, dass der Oberkörper, der interessiert uns einfach nicht. Nee, man kann mit den Beinen so viel machen. Es ist doch ... Ja, die Macher von Riverdance haben sich immer gedacht so,
in den Beinen steckt mehr Potenzial. In den Beinen steckt alles. Wir haben geguckt, was kann der Oberkörper leisten und wir sind zum Ergebnis gekommen, eigentlich ist es nicht wert, dass wir dem auch so eine kleine Welle oder irgendwie so einen Schnitten geben. Wohingegen so dieser klassische Twist relativ Oberkörper betont ist.
Richtig, eigentlich müsste man das kombinieren. Unten Riverdance, oben Twist und dann der Kopf noch den Robot oder so. Und da hätte ich dann Interesse. Das finde ich dann wieder interessant. Das klingt wahnsinnig kompliziert und schwierig. Aber okay, ich bin da sehr offen und würde wahnsinnig gerne so einen Hiphop-Tanzkurs überlegen. Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, wenn du zum Beispiel Ballett tanzt, das ist ja glaube ich ein Tanz, den du jetzt in einem klassischen Fire-Club-Setting nicht so gut umsetzen kannst, aber du hast trotzdem enormes Körpergefühl und bist grazil. Du weißt, wo deine Glieder sind. Du weißt, wo deine Glieder sind, aber ich glaube, das hält dich nicht auf, weil du willst jetzt nicht anfangen, eine Pirouette zu machen im Club, sondern du musst trotzdem noch improvisiert tanzen, hast aber trotzdem eine enorme Körperbeherrschung. Und das, glaube ich, ist eine gute Kombination, nicht genau die Moves zu kennen, aber eine gute Körperbeherrschung zu haben aus zum Beispiel Ballett. Eigentlich sollten wir Ballett tanzen. Hatten wir letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, dass ich ein Schizoider Typ bin? Ja. Ja, weil, und ich habe kein Körpergefühl, ich weiss nicht, weiß selten, wo meine Füße sind, oder, also weil wir sind so in unserem Kopf zu Hause. Ich glaube, das ist genau was, was wir lernen müssen. Und Yoga hat mir da, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen geholfen. Mit Yoga merkst du relativ schnell, wo deine Gliedmassen sind, weil das wird anstrengend. Es stimmt total. Das ist Strecken und so, und Dehnen. Ja, aber auch bei mir ist es oft so, wenn man was dreht oder so und man spielt die Szene und man hat ja so ein Bild von sich selbst, wie man aussieht, so ein bisschen in der Szene und denkt sich, okay, wie will ich das machen, wie will ich wirken und dann guckt man auf dem Monitor die Szene nochmal an und denkt sich, so sehe ich aus, das ist doch nicht dein scheiß Ernst, ich sehe aus wie eine Schildkröte, wo irgendwie der Kopf so ganz lang nach vorne ist, wie irgendwie aus Zoomania oder so diese Schildkröten. Können wir das bitte nochmal drehen mit weniger Schildkröten? Und alle so, das würde uns 20.000 Euro kosten. Und alle so, nee, dafür wurdest du gecastet. Du bist halt so ein bisschen schildkrötig. Aber wie ist es gerade bei dir so? Du drehst ja gerade viel. Wie ist es so Macht es Spaß am Set, Set-Live? Super viele Nachtdrehs, was verrückt ist. Und super viel warten. Also es ist auch meine Erfahrung. Unfassbar viel warten. Vor allem, ich habe nicht so wahnsinnig, also viele rödeln rum am Set. Es ist wahnsinnig wuselig und rumrödelig. Und ich sitze ja die ganze Zeit dann da nur hinter der Kombo, wo dann das Bild gezeigt wird, was gerade gedreht wird und so. Und es wird ja nicht, also netto wird nicht so viel gedreht. Muss man ja sagen, du bist ja auch nicht nur als Autor dabei, sondern jetzt auch am Set dabei, am Drehen. Ja, genau. Und es macht schon Spaß, aber es passiert auch oft nichts. Und da habe ich mir jetzt dann so oft mal ein Buch geschnappt und so und dann viel gelesen. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich im Westen nichts Neues gelesen. Erster Weltkrieg-Drama.
Klassische Nebenbeilektüre. Was im Set von How to Sailor Black Online-Festafel drei, also man muss sich schon immer wieder kurz umgucken, wo ist man denn gerade, wenn man so im Buch versunken ist und dann heisst es Und bitte und dann wackelt Florian hinten über dem Bildschirm, dann denkt man kurz, was ist hier gerade los, man denkt aber auch und das ist dann gefährlich, das ist alles völlig scheißegal, was wir hier machen.
Ja. Das, darum geht's, dass das nicht wieder passiert. Kein Krieg und dann hungern die rum und dann wissen die nicht, und dann freuen die sich, dass ihre Kameraden sterben, weil sie ja dann mehr zu essen bekommen, zum Beispiel mal so weirde Gedanken, die in diesem Buch generell. Und du mitten im Dreh, Leute, können wir ganz kurz mal aufhören, können wir kurz alle mal uns besinnen, dass es bitte nicht mehr dieses scheiß Bündnissystem gibt, das letztendlich dazu geführt hat, dass ganz Europa aus dem Konflikt, nein, der ursprünglich zwischen Serbien und Österreich und Ungarn, dass der eskaliert ist. Lass mich mal ausreden. Nee, stopp, stopp, stopp, lass mich mal los, bitte. Können wir da bitte kurz schauen, dass wir nicht mehr dieses Zwei-Fronten-System haben, dass Deutschland zwingt, Frankreich anzugreifen? So, danke, jetzt können wir weitermachen mit dem Quatsch. Puh, ach so, und dann wieder hinsetzen und wieder lesen. Aber dieses Realität, Fiktion ist auch immer total spannend, weil ich meine, in der Serie geht es ja auch viel um Polizei natürlich. Und interessanterweise sind viele der Leute, die Polizisten spielen, also auch so Statisten, sind echte Polizisten. Ja, das ist wahnsinnig seltsam. Das ist total merkwürdig. Generell immer so SEK-Beamte und so sind ja, viele von denen habe ich wiedererkannt, weil die bei guter Arbeit auch oft dabei waren, weil es sind nämlich immer die gleichen Nasen. Ja. Und es sind immer Berufspolizisten und es sind immer Leute, die so ein bisschen zu hart Leute anfassen, wenn es dann solche Szenen sind. Klar, aber dafür sind sie auch da. Weil die kennen das ja nicht anders. Und ich habe auch mal mit einem SEK-Beatmen gesprochen und so, wenn die halt dann Türen eintreten, um dann jemanden festzunehmen, ist da so ein Moment von Todesangst. Und ich habe zu Hause eine Familie vielleicht jetzt nur ein Kind, ich habe keinen Bock zu sterben. Und da entleert die natürlich auch ein bisschen was dann immer, kann man nicht ausschaltenalten und ich kann mir auch dann vorstellen, dass das auch übertragen wird, wenn man das mal, weil es
auf eine gewisse Art dann gelernt und dann bist du halt über so ein Filmset und dann gehst du
auf jemandem auf den Schauspieler los und dann vergisst du kurz, das ist ein Schauspieler. Es ist
total abgefahren, weil es... Einer meint das mal, Katjana oder du, ich meinte mal, ich habe Katjana
bei dem Geldwäsche... Genau, ja, ja, da wurde sie auch echt umgeknüppelt, das war schon echt hart. Das ist auch so absurd. Und dann einfach so, wo der Regisseur dann so ganz locker sagt so, aha, und wie würdet ihr das machen, so jemanden zu Boden drücken? Na so! Na so! Und dann, aha, und habt ihr vielleicht eine andere Variante? Ja, wir haben so ein paar verschiedene Griffe, ja, zeig die mal. Und das Schauspiel ist mit leeren Augen einfach so wow, wow, wow und dann baff jedes Mal.
Und dann bin ich wieder am Rand.
Gewalt führt uns in die schwierigsten Situationen.
Genau, die Gegengewalt, wenn man die diplomatischen Kanäle offen gehalten hätte.
Kann man unter Registr, kann man hier auch Stefan becken.
In einem Buch.
Ja, wo offensichtlich gerade erst angelesen wurde, weil man sieht das Eselsohr noch, also der drei. Aber es ist echt absurd, weil da war es dann so, da gibt es dann immer das Set, da gibt es auch noch das Lager, wo man dann sozusagen ist, wenn man nicht gerade dreht und so. Und da stehen dann auch immer viele rum und dann stehen auch manchmal die Polizeiautos da, die für die Szeneene gebraucht werden und da war es jetzt einmal so dass das lager neben der strasse war und auf dieser strasse gab es einen verkehrsunfall und dann kam halt die echte polizei mit mit blaulicht und sirenen kam an und aber auch direkt daneben standen wirklich 20 polizisten und ein sektrupp und diese leute Leute in dem Autounfall mussten sich denken, was geht denn bitte jetzt ab, wie das ist ein Autounfall und hier stehen diese Maschinenpistolen stehen da rum und halt wirklich fünf Polizeiautos und das ist wirklich so absurd und auch wir gucken dazu alle in Polizeiuniformen, schauen da so zu, was da ist und dann trifft sich der Blick mit dem echten Polizisten in so einem, keine Ahnung, gibt es jetzt keinen. Grüsst man sich? Ich weiß es nicht, grüsst man sich. Aber gab es den Moment in dir, wo du begst, hinzugehen und die Personalien aufzunehmen vielleicht? Ne, das nicht. Also man muss sagen, es war kein schwerer Unfall, nichts ist passiert, aber es war halt einfach so eine Routine, man muss halt schaden, bla bla bla. Und am Ende hieß es dann auch so, ja, weil da ist eine Rollerfahrerin hinten einem Auto aufgefahren und es hieß dann auch, die Rollerfahrerin war so abgelenkt von dem Lager, von dem Drehlager, dass sie nach rechts geguckt hat und gegen das Auto gefahren ist. Also es ist absurd. Sie war abgelenkt von den Polizisten, daher kam dann die echte Polizei, die sich vermischt hat. Die werden auch abgelenkt und sind dann auch in ein Auto gefahren. Ich hätte es so lustig gefunden, wenn einer von den Statisten dann irgendwie nicht gecheckt hat, was passiert und sich so ins echte Polizeiauto setzt und dann mit dem fährt und dann irgendwie diese, diesen
Typen auf dem Revier haben so,
wer sind Sie denn nochmal?
Ich warte auf den Trieb.
Kriege ich von Ihnen das Geld oder?
Dass sich diese Welten so
vermischen und ein echter Polizist
ist dann als Statist und dann so, ich habe gehört,
da wird jetzt jemand verhaftet irgendwie und dann
ganz merkwürdig. Wo liegt denn
Rinseln?
Ja, also es ist absurd, also diese Vermischung, Da wird jetzt jemand verhaftet irgendwie und dann ganz merkwürdig. Wo liegt denn Rinseln?
Ja, also es ist absurd.
Also diese Vermischung realer Welt und Fiktion ist schon weird.
Voll, das ist richtig seltsam, aber völlig nicht so schlecht.
Vor allem die arme Autofahrerin, die dann auch so dachte, was passiert hier gerade?
Also wirklich total absurd. Ich glaube, ich bin auch nervös automatisch.
Wie man das erkennt, wenn man Polizei im Straßenverkehr erblickt, wird man immer ein bisschen nervös und fährt ganz unauffällig. Ich mache mit der Weile alles Licht an, was ich habe. In meinem erbärmlichsten Move aller Zeiten nehme ich immer meine Kopfhörer ab. Ja. Weil technisch gesehen, glaube ich, darf man diese Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer nicht aufhaben. Vielleicht noch mehr auf, denke ich mir. Ich denke mir so, als ob jetzt in der Kölner Innenstadt bei 50 kmh irgendein Polizeistreifenwagen mich jetzt rauswinken würde und sagen, tschüss, Sie dürfen keine Kopfhörer tragen. Okay? Tschüss. Tschüss. Okay, sorry. Ja, wobei, also ich denke mir auch immer so in der Innenstadt dann, wenn eine Polizei lang wird, die haben noch andere Probleme. Die suchen noch andere Dinge. Private Schwierigkeiten. Die haben noch private Probleme. Ich denke mir so, in einer Großstadt wie Köln passiert doch bestimmt jetzt gerade was Schlimmeres. Also als ich mit meinem Kabelsalat, wo dann so der Stecker fast immer in die Speichen geht. Die werden doch gerade irgendwie, da ist doch ein Clan oder sowas, auf dem Ring unterwegs. Zum Beispiel, wir hatten es ja, ich habe ja versagt. Ich habe ja in meiner Aufgabe als guter Bürger mit Zivilcourage ja versagt, habe ich ja erzählt. Es gab diese Situation mit den beiden Nummernschildern, dass ich beobachtet habe, wie in meinem Innenhof das finstere Gestalten Nummernschilder ausgetauscht haben und ich lange mit mir gerungen habe, ob ich jetzt die Polizei rufen soll, die Polizei informieren soll, die Fake-Polizei rufen soll, mit meiner Fake-Uniform selber eingreifen soll, was jetzt genau passieren soll. Das wäre das Spannendste. Ja, das wäre richtig gut.
Was machen Sie da? Und dann direkt Schüsse, direkt Feuer eröffnet. Ja, und ich habe nichts gemacht. Und eine aufmerksame Zuhörerin des Podcast-UFO ist Polizistin und hat mir geschrieben und mir auch ein bisschen ins Gewissen geredet und meinte so, nee, da kann man schon mal die Polizei informieren, mein Lieber. Du hast sie aber auch so gelesen, diese Nachricht.
Ich habe sie auch so gelesen.
Du hast gelesen, Polizist, und dann liest man das ja auch
auch in diesem pädagogischen Ton. Genau. Und seitdem dachte ich mir, verdammt, ich will meine Zivilehre wiederherstellen, ich will wieder Teil der Gesellschaft sein, ich will für Recht und Ordnung sorgen und gehe deswegen seitdem mit offenen Augen durch die Welt. Und der gewählten Eins als Null. Eins als Null ist immer gewählt bei mir, immer.
Daumen auf der Null. Und dann eines Nachts bin ich aufgewacht, schreie. Schreie, Tumult, Aufruhr, Lärm auf der Strasse vor meiner Wohnung. Nein. Und du direkt. Und ich dachte mir, was ist hier los? Und tatsächlich bei mir ist oft Lärm, weil ich so ein bisschen aus reiner Dummheit irgendwo an so einer Partymeile wohne, wo immer Lärm ist und ich einfach sehr geräuschempfindlich bin. Und mein Leben ist die Hölle. So, alles ein anderes Thema gerade. Und Lärm und man denkt sich so, ja, keine Ahnung, was ist da los, bis es plötzlich hieß Hilfe, Hilfe, Polizei, Polizei. Und ich dachte mir, fuck, okay, was jetzt? Ich springe auf, Licht an, Rollladen hoch, sehe, ich wohne dritten Stock, sehe unten bei mir vor der Wohnung Schlägerei. Ich dachte mir, das ist jetzt der Moment. Jetzt kann ich aktiv werden und fange an zu filmen. Hol mein Handy raus. Warum hast du nicht Polizei gerufen? Weil es schon Polizeirufe gab. Es gab schon Rufe nach Polizei und da waren eine Menge Leute da unten. Und ich fange an zu filmen und es dauert auch nicht lange, dauert 20 Sekunden und die Polizei kommt. Aber was für Polizei. Wirklich bestimmt 50, 60 Polizisten kamen an. What? Blaulicht, überall mit Polizeihunden, mehrere Polizisten mit Kameras kamen.
Es war eine große Menschenmenge, aber wirklich eine Grauferei war nur so zwischen zehn. Aber es war schon einiges los und die kamen da sofort angerannt und Leute und zehn die auseinander und hat sich relativ schnell geklärt eigentlich dann. Aber ich hatte dieses video und danach habe ich dann noch so ein
bisschen geguckt und dann haben die polizisten noch mit allen gesprochen mit allen leuten zeugen auf aussagen aufgenommen wo ich mir immer denke es ist ja bestimmt nahezu unmöglich so eine schlägerei zu rekonstruieren weil du hast da fünfzig leute und die sagt ja der hat den da gezogen und der und ich weiß nicht der und wer ist das überhaupt und wer und wo und wo ist der hin und was ist los und hätte man da nicht irgendwie diplomatisch eingreifen sollen und warum gewalt nicht generell ein Problem letztlich diese starren Bündnessysteme auch dazu geführt, also wo ist die Schuldfrage überhaupt angebracht, so diese ganzen Sachen und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich habe jetzt dieses Video gemacht und jetzt natürlich, ich höre schon die Kommentare klackern, die Tastaturen schon klackern, ah Voyeurismus, irgendwie so, aber ich habe das wirklich mit einem Hintergedanken, ich will der Polizei helfen, ich will das Film als Beweismaterial, habe aber auch gemerkt, dass ich extrem dreckige Fenster habe. Also wirklich extrem und es fällt einem normalerweise, fällt mir normalerweise nicht so auf, aber da habe ich schon gemerkt so heieieiei, also das sind schon echt zu dreckig, das sieht schon echt nicht gut aus. Und vielleicht muss es ja auch nicht, also das wird ja... Das ist ja auch nur, ich meine, das ist nur Schlägerei. Genau, das ist... Drei Wochen Bewährung oder so. Ja mein Gott, da passiert, also das wird, das ist, weil, also dafür jetzt, und dann habe ich wirklich... Aber die Fenster sind echt dreckig. Und dann habe ich wirklich mit mir gerungen, so, weil das sieht schon echt, echt nicht gut aus gut aus. Aber irgendwann habe ich dann, da war dann irgendwie schon drei, vier Uhr nachts oder so, da dachte ich mir... Ich dachte dir kurz, du spiegelst dich in dem Video. Und das ist dir unangenehm. Splitter nack. Weil du so innen drin irgendwie Licht angemacht hast, dann kann man das, wenn man rausfilmt, spiegelt so ein bisschen, man sieht dich irgendwie oberkörperfrei, wie du mit grossen Augen runterguckst auf die Strasse und anfeuerst, hätte ich mir auch überlegt, das verdienen zu schicken, aber dreckige Fenster ist, finde ich, ich verstehe es, so. Ich habe fucking dreckige Fenster, putzt du deine Fenster? Nee, da kommt da eine Firma tatsächlich, die von aussen ...
Es ist echt, es money is back.
Nein.
Von aussßen? Ja, die Hausverwaltung regelt das dann. Oh, jetzt habe ich ganz lange in die falsche Richtung geschmacht. Ja, und dann kommt tatsächlich von außen kam dann so ein... Das war sehr lustig, weil ich so einen Boxersturz quasi in Unterhöschen standig vom Kühlschrank morgens und habe mir so Eier rausgekramt, schlaftrunkenden Augen. Und dann kam so ein Steiger hoch mit so einem Typen mit so Priel in so einer Flasche und er hat dann so das Fenster angesprüht plötzlich. Und dann habe ich mich wahnsinnig erschrocken und er hat so winkend davor gestanden. Auch eine klassische Winksituation.ituation. Es war eine klassische Wink-Situation. Vor allem auch dieses Scheibenwischen ist ja schon fast ein Winken. Und du einfach zurück. Nee, ich habe gewunken, aber er hat nur die Scheibe gewischt. Das war unangenehm. Ja, aber dann kam der so hochgefahren am Haus, so ganz langsam. Er hat sich so einen Kopf hochgeschoben. Aber wie gut es gibt, wenn du am Fenster gestanden hest und so aus dem Fenster guckst und der so ganz langsam.
Da kann es auch nicht gehen, weil man hat schon Augenkontakt seit der halben Stunde. Genau, und dann, oh, mir fällt ein, ich muss noch weg. Also ich habe mich dann letztendlich irgendwann dazu entschlossen, dieses Video als Beweismaterial einzureichen und habe gegoogelt, Polizei Köln, wie mache ich das, E-Mail? Info at. Hallo, hallo, at köln.polizei.de oder polizei.köln.de. Und da stand dann auch gross, bei der E-Mail-Adresse stand dann auch gross, eine E-Mail ist kein Notruf. Bitte senden Sie nicht in Notrufsituationen. I can relate, I can, so I can relate. Total. Also ich bin immer, egal wie schlimm es ist, immer erst mal Mail.
Immer Mail.
Es ist so, ich brauche einen Termin beim Amt.
Und dann steht auf der Website, wenn sie anrufen, kriegen sie innerhalb von drei Tagen Termin, bei einer Mail so innerhalb von den nächsten 18 Monaten. Ich überlege, ob es Zeit.
Nö, also es eilt ja nicht so doll.
Kein Problem, ich brauche keinen Pass.
Zack, 18 Monate, ist okay.
Aber auch da dachte ich mir so, ja, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, ich befinde mich gerade in einer Situation der körperlichen Bedrängung. Ich werde ausgeraubt im klassischen Sinne nach Strafgesetzbuch 222, räuberische Erpressung. Eine Waffe ist im Spiel. Wenn Sie Zeit haben, wäre es gut, wenn Sie mir kurz Unterstützung helfen könnten. Hochachtungsvoll, Florentin will. Und dann wieder wegmachen. Nee, doch lieber, liebe Grüße, Florentin. Liebe, mit Hochachtungs, na, LG, Florentin. Ciao, ciao. Und dann habe ich diese E-Mail geschrieben, auch merkwürdig so eine E-Mail zu formulieren, so, Selle der Damen und Herren. Betreff, deichige Fenster.
Ich liebe es übrigens, weil der Betreff ist so wichtig.
Der Betreff ist so wichtig.
Und man überlegt sich halt auch so, wie geckig kann man sowas schreiben. Ich mache Betreff immer geckig.
Meistens schreibe ich schon den Inhalt, weil ich habe oft kurze Mails, so mit Anhängen,
für den Dreh zum Beispiel so, wenn man das sehen, nochmal Änderungsseiten und so.
Und ich schreibe immer den Betreff schon hier, das haben wir nochmal geändert,
wegen und dann ist das der Betreff, weil ich liebe es Leute, weil das kostet so viel Arbeitszeit, wenn du immer wieder Mails finden musst und die nicht richtig angetextet hast im Betreff, das ist sehr lustig. Es ist immer gut, Leuten Arbeit zu machen. Total. Und man hat bei der Polizei so einen humorlosen Leser immer vor Augen und denkt sich, wie gackig kann man sein? Ist es jetzt so wirklich nur die harten Fakten? Und ich habe dann halt geschrieben, wann und was ich beobachtet habe. Und ich denke, wir wollen nicht strafbar machen. Nicht strafbar machen, nicht jetzt irgendwie noch Nebensatz den Holocaust leugnen, das wäre jetzt ganz, ganz schlecht. Und auf jeden Fall die Kopfhörer absetzen. Und dann habe ich es abgeschickt mit dem ganzen Video. Ich habe mir gedacht, soll ich das Video schneiden? Weil ich habe halt... Das ist offensichtlich mit weißen Schnitten. Ich habe das halt gefilmt. Und dann plätschert das Video halt so aus, so vier Minuten lang so. Und dann irgendwann gehe ich halt auch wieder ins Bett und mache halt die Kamera ein bisschen arg spät aus. Und dann liege ich halt schon wieder im Bett und denke, eigentlich will ich es nicht schneiden, weil das ist ja Beweismaterial, das ist ja so, wo ich denke, ich habe es halt einen ungeschnitten, dachte ich mir, ich füge es lieber ungeschnitten an. Mit Credits dafür. Mit Credits. Vielen Credits. Und ich winke am Ende auch nochmal so in die Kamera und gebe Thumbs up. Und für unseren Absp, so ein Movie-Abspann. Viel Erfolg bei der Ermittlung hier Florentin. Oder die Diashow. Ja, mit dem Cops-Intro. Bad Boys, Bad Boys. Und dann hast du halt so ein 150-Megabyte-Video. Überlegst du auch so Dropbox oder WeTransfer. WeTransfer, ja tatsächlich WeTransfer Link, schön reingeparkt und ich habe noch nicht so oft überprüft wie diesen Link, ob das das richtige Video ist, weil da willst du nicht das falsche Video anhängen. Ich habe mir auch überlegt, auch da auch für unser klassisches, wie viel halten die sozialen Stützen aus. Angenommen, ich hätte da jetzt wirklich ein massiv falsches Video angehängt, irgendwie so eine Folge Turtles oder so. Also eine ganze Folge Turtles. Und dann siehst du so, WeTransfer, Polizei Köln hat ihr ein Video runtergeladen. Hätte da die Polizei Köln geantwortet, sehr geehrter Herr Will, vielen Dank für Ihre E-Mail. Es kann sein, dass sie vielleicht das falsche Video angehängt hat oder kommt da nichts. Auf jeden Fall kam dann irgendwann die E-Mail, ja, es wurde weitergeleitet an die Polizeidirektion und seitdem nichts. Kein Geld, kein Preis. Keine Kommentare zu dringend Fenster, keine Kommentare, nicht irgendwie noch mal einen frechen Verweis. Ein frecher PS. Gar nichts. Kein Geld, kein Preis. Keine Kommentare zu dränken Fenster, in Deutschland? Keine Kommentare, nicht irgendwie noch meinen frechen Verweis. Frecher PS. Gar nichts und ja, tatsächlich, dieses dränkige Fenster ist bei mir tatsächlich so ein Blindspot. Eigentlich in der Regel Was ein Sinneswort ist? Blind, blinde Fenster. Also ich bin ja auch ein sehr dreckiger Mensch, glaube ich, und mir ist das egal. Und ich habe eine hohe Toleranz für Schmutz und so in der Wohnung und mache in der Regel nur sauber, wenn halt Besuch kommt oder halt auch Damenbesuch kommt. Und auch da habe ich dann wirklich so, wirklich meine komplett, wirklich so den ganzen Tag eingeräumt, komplette Wohnung sauber machen, alles geputzt, wirklich jede Ecke und alles, aber habe komplett die Fenster übersehen, weil ich das gar nicht auf dem Schirm habe. Und tatsächlich hat besagte Dame irgendwann mal zwei Wochen später gemeint so, du hast schon echt sehr dreckige Fenster. Und ich war sofort im Trotzmodus, ich putze für dich meine ganze scheiß fucking Wohnung und du meckerst über die Fenster. Aber rückblickend ergibt das alles total Sinn, weil meine Fenster wirklich fucking dreckig sind. Ja, Fenster habe ich aber auch nicht auf dem Schirm, weil die sind so, die sind nicht mehr Teil meiner Wohnung. Nee, die gehören nicht dazu. Das ist die Grenze. Das ist wie so, wenn man sich duscht die Beine so, du putzt nicht deine Beine. Ich mache ja die Wände nicht, also die sauber. Nee. Wände sind ja Wände, da hört die Wohnung ja dann auch irgendwo auf. Du putzt ja nicht die Decke. Nee, wo kommen wir denn da an? Wer hat jemals, vielleicht muss man seine Decke regelmäßig putzen. Doch schon, weil in den Ecken hocken die Spinnen. Ja gut, aber da kannst du schön im Staubsauger den Rüssel machen. Den Rüssel machen? Da ist ja kein Problem, schön im Rüssel. Du saugst die Spinnen weg, ne? Kennst du da nichts? Stellst du dir manchmal vor, wenn du Staubsaugst, dass du ein Elefant bist? Ja, ja. Ich auch. Ja. Mir macht immer mehr Spaß. Aasen-Ameisenbär, denke ich manchmal auch. Mir macht immer mehr Spaß, mit Hand zu saugen. Also nicht mit dem langen Stiel, sondern dann nochmal abklinken und dann noch in Nahkampf gehen. Dann nochmal den Dolch. Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, da habe ich mehr Macht. Also da bin ich auch irgendwie wendiger. So ich bin equipped. Bei diesem langen Stiel denke ich mir, es fühlt sich auch unnatürlich an.
Es fühlt sich unnatürlich an, irgendwie man weiß nicht genau, ob da noch was ist. Ich will so richtig rein, ich will wirklich auf kurze Distanz wirklich so Handgemenge mit dem kurzen und dann mache ich immer so, als wäre ich ein Elefant. Putzen ist generell etwas, auch ein bisschen so Klischee, wir zwei Jungs können nicht putzen, aber kann ich wirklich gar nicht. Ich weiß nicht, für welchen Lappen, für welche Oberfläche. Ich bin dann mal im Rewe gewesen, habe mir dann alle Lappen mal gekauft, man weiß nicht, wann man sie braucht. Und da habe ich dann gesehen Fensterleder. Und dann dachte ich, ah, ah, okay. Das war dann der Moment, wo ich dachte, ja, Fenster müssen auch putzen. Ja. Ich weiß auch nicht, dann, also was macht man dann mit dem Boden, mit dem Parkettreiniger, okay, Bad total, dann gibt es aber auch so einen Entkalker, ist Bad total, nicht auch der Entkalker drin, brauche ich auch noch einen Entkalker? Im Grunde definieren diese Putzprodukte so ein bisschen, was man tatsächlich putzt. Weil da gibt es dann so die für Chromoberflächen oder so der Wasserhahn. Ja, Edelstahl, Mr. Masler. Und das mache ich dann. Und dann Boden mache ich. Und alles, wofür es kein explizites Produkt gibt, wird auch nicht geputzt. Nee, muss auch nicht geputzt werden, denke ich mir dann. Da gibt es schon sehr viel. Da muss man auch ein bisschen aufpassen, dass man da nicht den Anschluss verliert, glaube ich. Ja.
Aber da bin ich wirklich, hänge ich ganz doll hinten dran. Da muss man sich aber auch mal irgendwie so einen Ruck geben und sowas. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dafür, aber wo fängt man dann an? Also, how do I start the process? Gibt es dann eine Masterclass oder sowas? Oder keine Ahnung. Werbung. Boah, ey, lesen ist so anstrengend. Ich glaube, das alte Buch auf versucht zu lesen ist es so anstrengend. Es ist so schwer für die Augen, es tut so weh. Warum ist es einfacher zu hören, als bei den Augen was zu lesen? Weil es sind ja beide Sinne, wie dem auch sei. Ja, deine Ohren sind ja immer offen so. Und zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, einschlafen willst oder so, aber keinen Bock hast, noch Licht anzumachen, kannst du einfach ein Hörbuch hören.
Ich bin fast komplett auf Hörbücher umgestiegen, auch natürlich wegen dem fantastischen Service von Thalia. Denn Thalia bietet wirklich einen fantastischen Service. Man kann 50.000 Titel, gibt es da, aus denen man wählen kann. Es kostet nur 9,95 Euro pro Monat. 30 Tage könnt ihr das gratis testen, ob es euch zusagt, also warum denn nicht? Ihr könnt das online tun, offline tun, via Smartphone, Tablet, Computer, also auch ohne Internetverbindung, auch im ICE, gleich in der Spitze an die Deutsche Bahn, aber auch da könnt ihr ein Hörbier hören. Bei einem Waldspaziergang, auf dem Boot, im Weltraum, falls ihr auf der ISS wohnt. Gibt bestimmt noch ein ganz tolles ISS-Hörbuch. Schaut einfach mal vorbei bei talia.de slash podcast minus ufo und guckt mal, was euch gefällt. Also jetzt viel Spaß beim Hören. Werbung. Aber irgendwo denke ich mir auch so, dass der Eke irgendwann auch wieder abnimmt. Ich stelle mir das immer so vor. Du bist schon weiter. Das ist mein Problem. Weil du bist nämlich schon weiter. Du denkst nämlich schon weiter, wie muss ich es gar nicht erst lernen.
Genau, ich denke immer so, jeder kennt die Situation, man schneidet irgendwie eine Zwiebel und einem fällt so ein Stück Zwiebel hinter einen Schrank oder so oder hinter die Ablage oder irgendwo hin, wo man nicht hinkommt. Und man denkt sich, naja.
Weil, klar, die Zwiebel, die wird jetzt wahrscheinlich unangenehm, aber ab einem gewissen Punkt kippt es wieder und die ist dann halt einfach Staub oder Erde oder halt irgendwas, weil nichts kann unendlich lange riechen, oder? Weil Geruch ist ja auch, dass die halt sowas raushauen. Man kann auch Dinge wegriechen, denke ich mir auch. Das ist die alte Frage. Aber dann ist die Frage, also jetzt mal zum Beispiel so halt irgendwas. Diese Diddle, diese parfümierten Diddle-Hefte. Genau. Die können ja auch nicht für immer riechen. Die wir gerade getauscht haben und so auch sagte, oh, da war aber offensichtlich eine Pause, eine lange Pause zwischen Pokémon und Yu-Gi-Oh, wo man Diddle-Hefte getauscht hat. Was war das für eine weirde Zeit? Ganz merklich. Wie so eine Nachkriegswelt, wo man so getauscht hat. Ja, so vor allem, als die Leute irgendwie nichts zu essen hatten und die nur riechen und dann immer so an so Sachen riechen konnten. Alles riecht irgendwie weird. Für eine Idee gewesen. Ganz merkwürdig. Es gab auch immer so, ich habe immer so Simpsons, es gab irgendwie jedes Jahr so ein Simpsons-Sticker-Album mit Stickern. Und dann gab es auch manche Sticker, die hatten so ein Geruchsfeld oder so. Und das war immer so absurd, weil für mich hat es nicht mal im Ansatz nach dem gerochen, was es sein sollte. Und es hat auch alles gleich gerochen und es war irgendwie so, ich konnte mich damit gar nicht, und ich hatte immer das Gefühl, ich mache das kaputt, wenn ich dran rieche. Ich denke immer, je mehr ich dran rieche, desto weniger riecht es. So wie wenn ich eine Flasche Wasser habe. Je mehr ich trinke, desto weniger kann ich trinken. Und so war es beim Riechen auch immer, so eher luftanhalten, um da möglichst wenig wegzumachen. Ja, ich war jetzt, es war so ein bisschen mein Zwiebel-Äquivalent, es gab tatsächlich einen Rohrbruch bei mir. Oh. Und ich war halt dann zum ersten Mal weg, war halt in diesem besagten Retreat, wo dann noch die Yogastunden erfolgten. Und dann kam, ich war sehr bei mir, sehr gelassen. Und dann kam der Anruf von den Nachbarn unter mir, dass es bei denen massiv durch die Decke läuft. Und man denkt, das kann jetzt aber nicht wahr sein. Und dann gab es tatsächlich einen Rohrbruch. Aber das Beste daran ist, ist nicht wirklich mein Problem gewesen, weil mein Boden hat nichts abbekommen. Es war irgendwie in so einem Sicherungsschacht, kam es unten zum Rohrbruch, für den ich nichts konnte, war irgendwie aus Altersschwäche gestorben, das Rohr, hat dann einfach ein bisschen Wasser gelaufen. Dann hat meine Nachbarin, weil die einen Schlüssel, den Erlassschlüssel hat, hat dann die Klempner reingelassen, die unter mir, die Wohnung, die haben dann den Klempner gerufen und so. Und ich kam nach zwei Wochen wieder, meine Wohnung sah aus wie vorher. Perfekt! Und irgendwie, und die Rechnung kriegt das irgendwie die Hausverwaltung, wo man sagt, geil, also perfekt. Also ich habe mit dem ganzen Stress nichts zu tun gehabt und so, Probleme lösen sich alleine. Du gehst die Treppen hoch, unter dir alle weinen und verschuldet und so und irgendwann, je höher du steigst, desto weniger Probleme hast du und bist in einer Wohnung. Ich höre, zu weniger hat man auch die Schreie von unten und deswegen denkt man sich so, wow, eigentlich ganz geil. Also wieder die alte Theorie, Probleme lösen sich schon häufig alleine auch einfach.
Ja, so wie dieses Stück Zwiebel oder irgendwie so eine alte Banane, die so hinter den Kühlschrank fällt. Ausser das glaube ich. Außer das glaube ich. Nee, das kippt schon irgendwann wieder so, weil irgendwann hat das keine Kraft mehr zu riechen. Oder gewöhnt sich erst die Nase an diesen Geruch. Es ist halt auch die Frage, was stark riechen bedeutet. Heißt es, dass viel Zeug davon in der Luft ist oder dass du besonders stark darauf reagierst? Relativ darauf reagierst wahrscheinlich, ja. Weil so ein Brötchen, ein gutes Brötchen. Ja, angenommen, du hast jetzt hier so, weil ich hatte letztens eine Dose faule Bohnen und das will man nicht. Du willst keine Dose fauler Bohnen haben. Das ist nix. Moment, hast du die Dose aufgemacht? Weil das ist ja toll an Dosen. Ja. Da kann passieren drin, was du will. Wie lange? Ganz kurz, ganz kurz. Halten die nicht 20 Jahre? Nee, also normalerweise hast du ja so eine Dose Bohnen, so eine schöne Dose Kidneybone und die sind in so einem Schl einem Schlodder drin halt so. Weiß man auch nicht genau. Das war so aus Alien-Filmen, wo dann die Embryos immer auskommen. Und man nimmt das halt so hin, da sind die geboren, da leben die, da habe ich jetzt kein Problem mit. Ich habe es aufgemacht und dieser Schlodder war steif. Das war so wie so feste Gelatine. Und es war wirklich so fest du hast wirklich so den abdruck des deckels aber hatte ich nicht das noch versucht die bohnen raus und ich dachte mir halt so naja ich bin da sehr tolerant ich sagte naja wenn das für euch wenn das wenn das der schlodder dieser art bohne ist okay ja wenn ja manchmal ist der schlodder das ist so wie wenn man so ein Kind erzieht, ja manche Menschen haben halt festen Schlotter und manche haben halt flüssigen und das ist völlig okay.
Es ist die Bohnen.
Es geht am Ende um die Bohne und nicht um den Schlotter.
Und dann dachte ich mir, wollte ich das so ein bisschen wegwaschen, diese Gelatine-Zeug, und habe dann aber relativ schnell gemerkt, dass sich eine Geruchsentwicklung anbahnt, die sich nicht verträgt mit meinem normalen Anspruch, wie Dinge riechen sollten. Und es war extrem widerlich. Und bei mir ist meine Strategie mittlerweile, weil ich habe, das kennen wahrscheinlich viele, dass wenn man mal was faul oder schimmelig riecht, dass man das dann nicht mehr gut essen kann eine Zeit lang, weil man das dann immer diesen Geruch verbindet. Ich hatte auch faule Knoblauch und konnte dann nicht gut Knoblauch essen und ich wusste das und deswegen meine Strategie ist immer, sobald ich was Faules habe, sofort essen, also nicht das Faule natürlich, sondern sofort dann echte Bohnen essen. Das ist doch die beste Diät aller Zeiten. Dass man sich das langfristig abgewöhnt, dass man sich irgendwann alles Essen abgewöhnt hat. Stefan, esst Patent-Diät. Ich schreib's kurz auf. Weil, so, du kriegst von mir verschimmelte Pommes, verschimmelten Burger, verschimmelte Snickers, verschimmelte Pizza, verschimmelte Snickers. Isst du alles, was geil ist, du musst vorher eine Liste geben, kriegst du, verfault. Isst das alles und dann gehst du nach Hause. Das kostet dann 10.000 Euro, das ist so widerlich, dass du dir alles abgewöhnt hast. Okay, dass sich immer sagt, eigentlich das einzige, was ich noch esse, ist keine Sellerie, weil ich alles andere widerlich finde und dann isst man nur noch Sellerie und ist glücklich damit. Genau, zwischen jedem Verfaulten darf man ein Stück Sellerie essen.
Gute Idee, finde ich sehr gut.
Ist ein bisschen aufwendig, aber du hast dann so eine Art Museum,
wo alles ungesunde Essen
ausgestellt ist und da muss man,
hat man so Kästen, man muss jeden Kasten aufmachen
und dran riechen und dann sagen, ich esse nie
wieder. Dann bin ich so wie so jemand,
der jemand ertränkt, nehme ich den Kopf
dann immer so von der Vorwand und schick den in die Gulaschruppe
und dann wird noch ein bisschen
gewackelt und geschrien und so, aber meine Hand bleibt
Vielen Dank. Nee, dann bin ich so wie so jemand, der jemand ertränkt, nehme ich den Kopf dann immer so von der Vorhand und schick den in die Gulaschruppe und dann wird noch ein bisschen gewackelt und geschrien und so, aber meine Hand bleibt drauf und dann hoch. Oh, ich liebe ja, das ist wirklich. Dann ein Stück Sellerie und dann immer so Sellerie und dann so ja, erst wahrscheinlich nein, weil Sellerie mag niemand so richtig gern. Nee. Warum setzen sich so manche Dinge durch? Weil es gibt manche Dinge, wo Leute, wo niemand euphorisch mit ist. Ja. Also so Aubergine, so manches Gemüse wurde so mitgeschleppt, weil man es auch essen konnte. Weil Bäume, oder auch Avocados, denke ich mir immer, ich mag selber Avocados, aber die schmecken nicht wirklich nach was. Ja, aber ich finde auch so, es gibt ja Leute, die bauen das an, die haben sich dazu, weil wenn ich Bauer wäre, dann würde ich sagen, oh geil, hier so geile Kartoffeln, irgendwie so Bratkartoffeln oder Orangen oder was, was geil schmeckt. Aber es gibt ja Leute, die bauen dann irgendwie diesen Sellerie an oder so und du denkst dir so, das ist deine Leidenschaft. Sellerie. Vor allem, es gibt ja auch so manche Sachen, die haben nahezu keine Kalorien. Irgendwie dann so, ich glaube Sellerie oder so, es ist sowas, wo ich mir denke, wie konnte sich das überhaupt in der menschlichen Ernährung durchsetzen? Das muss ja das Mittelalter überlebt haben, wo es ja Hungersnöte gab, wo Leute gesagt haben, ich habe ein Feld und ich muss jetzt, was ich da anbaue, das bringt meine Familie durch den Winter. Wie kamen Leute auf die Sellerie? Welcher Vollidiot hat Sellerie durchgeschleppt?
Was mehr Kalorien beim Kauen verbraucht, als es dem Körper gibt.
Warum hat sowas überhaupt überlebt?
Welcher Vollidiot hat Sellerie durch diese Zeit gerettet?
Ganz im Ernst.
Das ist wirklich Luxus.
Ich glaube, auch so Tomaten oder so haben auch nicht viel Kalorien.
Warum hat sich das durchgesetzt, dass Leute gesagt haben,
du kannst ja nicht nur von Tomaten leben. Von Kartoffeln oder so, das kann ich mir vorstellen, auch wenn die es, glaube ich, im Mittelalter gab es noch gar keine Kartoffeln, aber ihr versteht, was ich meine, Rüben oder so ein Kram halt. Es ist auch in den Menschen irgendwie drin, so anders sein zu wollen. Und dann hat jeder so, oder hatten die halt schon diese Default-Gemüse-Sachen der Nachbar,
dann hat man sich aber überlegt, irgendwie die Sellerie durchzuschleppen.
Ja.
Weil irgendwer muss es ja gemacht haben, irgendwer muss sie durch die Zeit gerettet haben.
Ich verstehe es auch. so, oder hatten die halt schon diese Default-Gemüse-Sachen der Nachbar und dann hat man sich ja überlegt, irgendwie die Sellerie durchzuschleppen.
Ja. Weil irgendwer muss es ja gemacht haben, irgendwer muss sie durch die Zeit gerettet haben. Ich verstehe es auch nicht, ganz ehrlich, weil es gibt mit Sicherheit manche Gemüse, die sind nicht, niemand sagt, das ist mein Leibgericht oder sowas. Nee.
Und deswegen wird man so sein, dann wird man halt in diesen Trug, in so ein Aquarium, wo dieser Geruch sich befestigt hat von mir, von diesem verschimmelten Hamburger Royal TS.
Ja. in diesen Trug, in so ein Aquarium, wo dieser Geruch sich verfestigt hat von mir, von diesem verschimmelten Hamburger Royal TS, reingesicht. Nie wieder. So danach Sellerie. Und dann Lauch? Woher haben Sie Lauch? Ich baue das an bei mir zu Hause. Warum, Horry? Warum bauen Sie denn nicht irgendwie Äpfel oder eine geile Birne oder einen Kürbis von mir aus? Nee, ich pflanze Lauch an. Das, was man in Gerichte tut und sich dann nachdenkt, es wäre eigentlich geil gewesen ohne Lauch. Aber gut, das ist meine Erfahrung mit Lauch. Ja, so Lauch ist auch seltsam. Vor allem, ich finde auch, je normaler es aussieht wie eine normale Pflanze, desto weniger ist es anbaudürftig. Völlig korrekt. Weil bei so manchen Sachen beißt du einfach wie in so ein Gras. Kresse so. Ja, Kresse hat Kresse, Kresse hat doch wahrscheinlich null Kalorien, einfach wirklich null. Und trotzdem gibt es Leute, die sagen, ich mache lieber das. Also das ist ja Luxus, Kresse ist ja Luxus. Verdienen wir Geld mit Kresse anbauen. Ja, so Schnittlauch. Das wächst halt so auf. Schnittlauch schmeckt schon geil, aber das wächst halt auch so irgendwo. Es gab es immer so, manche Sachen konnte man immer essen als Kind, so auch Zitronenliste. Das ist wahrscheinlich Sauerampfer. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das schreiben würde, aber so Sauerampfer, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das... Genau, Wir brauchen Bayern gar keine andere Sachen. Ja, so Sauerampfer, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das... Gebrauchtig mit mir vor. Kennt jetzt wahrscheinlich einige Süddeutsche Länder, denken sich, oh, ich habe meine Kindheit sauer... Oder diese gelben Blumen, wo man so ein bisschen Nektar raussaugen konnte. Stimmt. Das war auch so ein Ding. Das weiß ich auch noch. Kennen das heute? Kennst du eine Thais das eigentlich? Das nochmal schön mit Freunden... Thais! Thais! Ruf mal ganz kurz an, bitte. Kennst du diese gelben, wo man die Blüten abzupft und dann so Nektar raussaugt? Oder hängst du den ganzen Tag auf TikTok und demonstrierst für eine CO2 freie Zukunft, dass die Gletscher und die Eisbären nicht schmelzen? Lass mal die Kohlekraft weggehen jetzt. Oh Gott, immer dieser erhobene Zeigefinger. Zeitverschwendung. Aber Thais, du machst einen guten Job.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich habe immer Brennnessel gegessen tatsächlich.
Weil du Schmerz geliebt hast.
Ich liebe Schmerz.
Du dachtest dir, das tut schon von außen weh.
Ich habe mich so... Weil eigentlich ja, stimmt, du hast recht, du hast ja im Magen keine Nerven.
Das heißt, selbst wenn die Brennnessel dir wehtun würden... Wow, da waren sehr sehr viele Anführungszeichen. Da war ich immer gefragt, was ist Schmerz? Okay, das ist jetzt die richtige Frage. Weil wenn du jetzt Brennnessel gegen ein Stück Holz drückst, kein Schmerz. Aber auch nur, weil das Holz ... Nicht schreien kann. ... keine Kapazität hat, Schmerz zu verspüren. Aber physikalisch passiert ja dasselbe, wie wenn du Brennnessel an die Haut drückst.
Irgendwo bei Galilie habe ich mal gehört, dass Bäume dieses Hormon für Schmerz aussondern haben. Weiß ich es auch nicht. Jedenfalls.
Stell dir mal vor, irgendwann kriegt man die Frequenz ins Radio gedreht vor Pflanzen. Und wir machen das an, so im Regenwald von Brasilien und du hörst einfach nur so Millionen Bäume. Würden wir unser, ich glaube, wir würden das unser Verhalten nicht ändern, sondern das Radio ausmachen. Wir würden über den gesamten Globus so ein riesiges Noise-Canceling-Earphones stülpen, die genau diese Frequ Rausfedern. Oder auch wenn du in die Blume gehst, so Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe,stern, so jedes alles hat der Fallstelle. Ja, kannst du oben anfassen, quetschen, sodass du die Unterseiten beide nach innen drückst, so und dann kannst du das ganze abreissen und dann kannst du sehr gut essen. Und es schmeckt fantastisch, du musst halt schnell kauen. Und manchmal kriegt die Zunge ein bisschen was ab. Warum schnell kauen, weil es verboten ist, oder was? Ja, damit die Polizei es nicht sieht. Nein, weil du ja nicht willst, dass die Brennnesselnesseln dir ins Gesicht stechen. Ach, die haben so ein bisschen Delay, oder was? In deine Fresse stechen. Nee, aber die soll kein sehr kaputt kauen. Von oben. Naja, das kannst du nicht was essen. Sehr lecker tatsächlich. Gibt ja auch Brennnesseltee und so. Fantastisch, wirklich lecker, lecker, schmackhaft. Fantastisch. Es ist fantastisch. Sorry, ich weiß, du bist ein sehr begeisterungsfähiger Mensch, aber ich würde dich kurz darauf festhalten, dass du den Geschmack als Brennnessel fantastisch nennst. Nee, nee, nee, ich glaube, es ist mehr das Gefühl gerade, du hast das Gefühl, bei Natur zu siegen, weil du wie so deren Waffe isst. 200 Millionen Jahre hast du einen Verteidigungsmechanismus entwickelt, um dich gegen Tiere zu schützen. Oh, hier. Ich esse dich genau wegen deines Verteidigungsmechanismus. So, this is me, meiner Pfarrfinderuniform. Ciao, eat this bitch. Ich habe den Brennnessel on. Ja, und dann Allergie, rote Augen. Jedenfalls kann man das gut essen und es schmeckt ganz okay. Zitronenliste kann man auch. Ganz okay. Ja, ich muss das revidieren auf jeden Fall. Bis mir dann mal irgendwer gesagt hat, ich habe es wirklich häufig gemacht, weil man auch doll beeindrucken konnte, war immer so, wow, Stefan, du kannst Brennnessel essen, was bist du, Superman, ja. Aber einer meinte mal, ja, das ist genau die Höhe, wo Hunde hinpinkeln und so. Und wirklich, ich sah die letzten drei Jahre an mir vorbeiziehen und dachte mir, ach Gott, wie so goldene Ströme von oben und du mit offenem Mund liegst und einfach, ja, das habe ich jahrelang gemacht. Das habe ich jahrelang gemacht. Ja, und deswegen glaube ich, liebe ich Hunde. Ich hatte mal für kurze Zeit einen grünen Daumen an Karneval. Ich hatte tatsächlich mal einen grünen Daumen. An Karneval? Nee, für einen Greenscreen. Achso, ich dachte nur, weil du mit einem Hammer irgendwie daneben gehörst. Mit einem grünen Hammer? Ne, ganz, ja wohl, ganz merkwürdige Story bei uns aus der Frank-Elster-Masterclass. Und zwar hatten wir einen Ich kenne das Gesicht, wie erzähle ich diese Geschichte? Und zwar hatten wir einen Dozenten, sag ich mal, dem hat die Hälfte von seinem Daumen gefehlt. Der hat einfach irgendwo einen Unfall gehabt und die hat ihm Hälfte von seinem Daumen gefehlt. Ja, gucken wir mal von da auch. Genau, aber der war da total cool damit irgendwie und hat auch selber immer Witze gemacht, irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, irgendwie halber Daumen hoch, bla bla bla. Und man konnte halt einfach cool Gags machen. Und dann hatte der irgendwann Geburtstag und dann war der aber nicht da und danach wollten wir dem zum Geburtstag so ein Video drehen, halt so als Geburtstagsgross. Und dafür dachten wir, wir machen alle uns einen halben Daumen und haben dadurch halt alle in so eine Greenscreenfarbe, unseren Daumen so zur Hälfte in Greenscreenfarbe gesteckt, sodass wir einen halben grünen Daumen hatten. Und dann haben wir uns dann halt vor Greenscreen gefilmt und alle hatten einen halben Daumen. Warum braucht ihr dafür einen Greenscreen im Hintergrund? Ja, doch theoretisch einfach nur. Warum? Nee, aber damit du einen Hintergrund hast. Brauchst du ja nicht. Nee, aber du weißt ja nicht, was du statt dem Daumen dann sonst zeigen sollst. Du, wir hatten ein Programm, wir hatten eine Woche Erfahrung mit Kameras. Warum hilft euch in der Hintergrund ein grün? Wenn du einfach nur einen grünen Daumen hast, dann kannst du den grünen Daumen ja nicht rausnehmen. Doch, du weißt, was dahinter sein soll. Ja, aber was hilft denn dann der grüne Greenscreen? Ja, dass du halt irgendwas anderes dahinter tun machst. Nein, dann musst du auch noch den Hintergrund ersetzen. Ja, aber den Hintergrund kannst du ja ersetzen. Du bist dann halt vor einer Palmwelt und dann passt's. Aber dann müssen alle den Daumen freigestellt nach oben. Ja, freigestellt natürlich, das ist schon klar. Und was ich auch sehr lustig fand, weil es sehr gut passt, weil du gerade WeTransfer angesprochen hast, bei WeTransfer kann man grosse Dateien hochladen und dann Leuten den Link schicken, damit die sich runterladen können. Sehen die eigentlich diese ganzen Videos. Und dann gibt es nämlich eine Funktion, dass wenn du deine E-Mail-Adresse angibst, kannst du eine E-Mail bekommen, wenn der andere das Video runtergeladen hat, damit du weißt, ah cool, es ist angekommen. Und wir haben dem eben dieses Video geschickt, so hey, kleiner Gruß von uns zum Geburtstag. Und er hat es nie runtergeladen. Nie runtergeladen und beim nächsten Mal, als wir ihn getroffen haben, auch so, ey cool, hast du so eine Geburtstagsgrusche bekommen, ja, ja, mega, total gefreut und so.
Und wir wussten alle, dass er es weder runtergeladen noch gesehen hat. Aber ja, cool, vielen Dank dafür nochmal. Was war denn im Video, was war denn mit unseren vielen Daumen?
Nee, vielen Dank für den Gruss, also für den Geburtstagsgruss.
Warst du fies oder?
Na, nee, also nee, gar nicht, war total cool. Hast du das gesehen? Ich habe mich gefreut über die Mail. Und jetzt belassen wir es auch. Nochmal die Frage, weil du musst ja den Hintergrund ersetzen. Du musst ja das Grün ersetzen. Ne? Ja. Ihr hättet, ich versuche es noch mal einen Schritt, ich wage es noch mal einmal, ihr hättet euch nicht vor Grün stellen müssen. Weil die Idee ist ja, bei Grün, Greenscreen, dass man die Farbe ersetzt. Ja. Und ihr wolltet ja einfach nur, ich habe es schon einfacher gemacht, klar. Die Frage ist ja, womit ersetzt du den halben Daumen? Aber kannst du nicht so eine St Daumen? Was liegt es auf dem Bild statt diesem Daumen? Wenn du ja keinen Greenscreen hast, musst du ja irgendwie dann den Hintergrund rekonstruieren, was ja unmöglich ist für unsere technischen Fähigkeiten. Wie standet ihr denn da? Ich hätte es auch nicht runtergeladen, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Wir standen da und haben Thumbs abgegeben, so dass der Daumen nicht vor unserem Körper ist. Das heißt, wir, ich habe Thumbs abgegeben. Und um ganz ehrlich zu sein, diese Scheissfarbe ist auch fucking schwer wieder wegzukriegen. Und ich hatte bestimmt zwei Tage danach noch so einen scheiss halb angegrünten Daumen, der einfach so aussah, als würde er mir abfaulen, was halt auch nicht so cool war. So, und das alles dafür, dass der Typ es nicht mehr runtergeladen hat. Habt ihr noch Kontakt mit ihm jetzt, oder? Nein, wie denn? Wie macht, wie fährt er denn, wie, kommt er klar, ja klar, man kommt schon klar, oder? Ja, man kommt klar. Ich glaube, man kommt, vor allem mein Gitarrenlehrer, habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal, mein Gitarrenlehrer hat auch ein halber Finger gefehlt, und zwar der einzige Finger, den man nicht zum Gitarrenspielen braucht, der rechte kleine Finger.
Alle anderen Finger brauchst du zum Gitarrenspielen und da fehlt genau der eine.
Gott, Herr, Gott.
Also das war auch so.
Aber hat er deswegen angefangen, Gitarre zu spielen?
Das ist natürlich die Frage. Oder hatte er irgendwie einen Sägewerkunfall und er war das glücklichste Unfallopfer jetzt. Klassischer Gitarrenhit. Das ist der beste Hit. Was war dein Lieblingssong für die Gitarre eigentlich? Oh, Prelude Nummer eins von Aitavija Lobosch. Lobosch. Ganz toll, ganz toll. Auch schon lange nicht mehr gemacht. Klassische Gitarre ist für einen Arsch. Total, naja, es ist schon ganz cool. Warum geht nie, warum ist niemand eine Generation an Kindern gegen klassische Gitarre auf die Strasse gegangen? Ja. Weil klassische Gitarre war immer, niemand will das lernen. Niemand will klassische Gitarre lernen. Es ist immer man will eigentlich Wonderwall können, aber niemand bringt einem Wonderwall bei.
Nein, weil ich glaube, erst, also ich glaube 1964 sind ja die Musiklehrer auf die Strasse gegangen, gegen Nothing Else Matters und gesagt haben keinen Bock mehr, wir bringen jetzt Ferdonando Carulli und Francesco Carcassi bei, die klassischen Gitarre. Carlo Colucci, wir bringen die Leute richtig so. Und einfach mal ein schönes Fingerring hier, dass man da richtig so einen schönen Fingersatz hat und nicht einfach nur immer so strummelt. Und ich glaube, da steht noch der Protest der Musikschüler wieder aus. Ich glaube, im Moment ist die Waagschale der Geschichte noch auf der Seite der Musiklehrer, was aber jederzeit sich ändern kann. Also kleiner schaut an alle Musikschüler, die Zeit ist vielleicht, naja, wartet noch ein Jahr, dann könnt ihr vielleicht demonstrieren. Bis dahin müsst ihr euch noch schön durchfingern. Mit euren Masken. Es gibt so ein lustiges Video, das ihr euch angucken könnt, falls ihr euch jetzt denkt, Moment mal, klassische Gitarrenmusik sagt mir jetzt gar nichts. Könnt ihr euch gerne angucken. Es gibt nämlich ein so ein YouTube-Video, das glaube ich so durch die Geschichte der klassischen Gitarrenmusik führt. Also dann anfängt irgendwie bei den ersten und dann halt so 1612 so lauten, barren, wie heißt es, lute, wie heißt es auf deutsch?
Laute.
Laute. Also dann anfängt irgendwie bei den ersten und dann halt so 1612 so lauten, barren, wie heißt das, Lute, wie heißt das auf deutsch?
Laute, lauten Musik und dann halt so die Entwicklung bis halt so modern abgefahren.
Das ist halt ein wirklich ernstes Video, halt wirklich so, wo so ein wirklicher Musiker einfach da sitzt und du hast auch so diese Isolatoren an der Wand und drei Mikrofone und das ist halt ein ernster Musiker und du weißt halt, okay, der nimmt seine Musik wirklich ernst.
Am Ende spielt er Miley Cyrus.
Und der führt dann da durch und der macht halt so eine Medley, der spielt halt so verschiedene Stücke an, um halt so einen Eindruck zu bekommen von der Geschichte der klassischen Musik für die Gitarre und spielt halt.
Und du siehst halt, wow, 1628, wow, so diese altehrwürdige Musik und du hast richtig das Gefühl, dass jetzt wirklich hier so die mit Gravitas so einmal die gesamte Musikgeschichte, so die Errungenschaft der Menschheit ist wirklich fantastisch, also wirklich und ein Mensch verkörpert das in sich, diese gesamte Fille an Musik und dann kommt er immer so weiter und es ist so ein Countdown, so von 100 bis 1, so das modernste Stück und dann spielt er wirklich so einen Fingersatz und ganz fantastisch und er ist wirklich so tief drin und spielt das wirklich so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingersatz und so ein Fingers, so ein Fingers, so ein Fingers, so ein Fingers, so ein Fingers, so ein Fingers ist so ein Countdown, so von 100 bis 1, so das modernste Stück. Und dann spielt er wirklich so einen Fingersatz und ganz fantastisch und er ist wirklich so tief drin und spielt das wirklich ganz virtuos und toll und du bist einfach verzaubert.
Und bei Stück drei hört er kurz auf zu spielen und greift so zum Boden und holt so einen kleinen pinken Mini-Ventilator, macht den an und spielt mit diesem pinken Mini-Ventilator die höchste Seite der Gitarre wahnsinnig schnell und spielt darauf das Stück, spielt dann so eine Melodie, macht den Ventilator, seinen kleinen pinken Ventilator wieder aus, muss auch pink sein, das war's. legt wieder auf dem Boden und spielt weiter. Und ich habe keine Luft bekommen, als ich das das erste Mal gesehen habe, weil ich so lachen musste. Das ist der längste Witz der Welt. Das ist wirklich so, vor allem die Vorstellung, was steht da in den Noten, steht da, ja, Andante, Capriccio, so vier Viertel, Takt, Pinto Ventilatore. Kennen Sie diese kleinen pinken Vini, die man manchmal bei Baumärkten, so in dieser ein Euro, an der Kasse, diese kleinen, jetzt nicht diese grossen Raumventilatoren, sondern diese kleinen Hand, kennen Sie die? Die von Prinzessin Lillifee, die man manchmal so für 1,99 Euro oder sowas sieht. Davon brauchen sie einen, damit spielen sie bitte die hohe E-Seite einfach wahnsinnig schnell. Es ist so verrückt einfach, wie das so komplett die Stimmung bricht und es klingt auch furchtbar eigentlich. Ich glaube, das war auch so ein Kommentar auf die Musik ist heute nichts mehr wert. Es ist ein ernsthaftes Stück, aber ich denke mir so, ist es denn, also hat das einfach ein extrem hohes Tempo. Das ist klassische Gitarre, ne? Ja, klassische Gitarre. Der hat am Ende nicht Hitman bei Womba-Time. Nein, nein, nein, das ist die Geschichte der klassischen, wie es auch heute ... Ja, postmoderne Musik, natürlich. Und die ist halt weird. Die ist halt weird. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das in dem Stück steht oder ob das einfach ein extrem hohes Tempo hat, was man menschlich gar nicht spielen kann. Nee, ich glaube, das steht bisher drin. Da steht so, holen Sie sich so einen kleinen Handel, hier ist ein ESPN-Code, bestellen Sie den. Ja, das ist so ... Hier ist ein Link. Ja,, auch Musik, wahrscheinlich lustig gemeint. Das glaube ich nicht. So John Cage-mäßig. Postmoderne Musik ist schon weird. Man weiß nicht, ob es lustig gemeint ist. Aber es war einfach komplett gebrochen. Einfach völlig absurd. Einfach die Tatsache, das ist genauso wie ein bisschen mit unserem Armin Kübler, Kübler, ich weiß nicht genau, wie er heißt, der die Saxophon spielt, vor dieser langen Röhre, wo einfach dann irgendwie die Eltern fragen so, na ma, möchtest du eigentlich ein Instrument lernen, wir würden dich da unterstützen und das Kind sagt, ja, ich würde gerne Saxophon spielen, aber vor so einer vier Kilometer langen Röhre. Ja, du, dann müssen wir gucken, ob eine VHS-Obs gucken, ob die da so eine Röhre haben. Ob die das anbieten. Ob die da Röhrensaxophon haben. Also wir müssen halt dann, bevor wir uns das anschauen. Der Lehrer dann so, nee, es gibt schon Tenorsaxophon. Oder halt dann das Alt, das ist ein bisschen tiefer. Nee, wir wollen wissen, ob wir ein vier Kilometer langes Rohr haben.
Also wirklich wie für so eine Pipeline oder für so einen Baudamm oder so.
Ich verstehe nicht. Meinen Sie so einen kleinen Aufsatz für Saxophon?
Nee, wir meinen wirklich so eine wirklich über den Horizont hinausgehende, extrem lange Betonröhre. Müsste ich überlegen. Müsste ich vielleicht, muss ich nochmal ins Musiklager, muss ich nochmal gucken. Thomann.de. Muss ich nochmal schauen. Bei Thomann haben die alles. Die haben wirklich alles, da kannst du alles bestellen. Oh, das fände ich toll. Aber absurd einfach. Ich hoffe, das haben sich ein paar Leute angeguckt. Hören sich Leute unsere Spätungen eigentlich an? Hört das hier noch irgendwer? Hallo? Hallo? Ich glaube, wir haben alle verloren mittlerweile durch die Sommerpause. Wir haben ein kleines Geständnis. Letzte Woche habe ich die Folge hochgeladen und da hast du mich sogar angerufen, ich habe die Folge hochgeladen im ICE. Und ja, jetzt kannst du wieder deinen zehnminütigen Stand-Up machen über ICE-Internet, dass es halt ein bisschen schwach auf den Beinen ist, dass es da manchmal ein bisschen wackelt. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, ja gut, das dauert jetzt wahrscheinlich eine halbe Stunde, bis die Folge hochgeladen ist, aber passt schon. Aber anscheinend war der Upload irgendwie nicht richtig, wurde der nicht richtig vollendet und die Folge war einfach nicht vollständig und hat eine halbe Stunde vor dem eigentlichen Ende ist sie einfach abgebrochen. Und diese Folge war bestimmt einen Tag lang online, bevor einer mal geschrieben hat, ey Leute, eure Folge bricht einfach mittendrin ab. Das stimmt nicht, es sehr viele geschrieben aber es hat wirklich lange gedauert es hat wirklich lange gedauert mit meinem guten Internet zu Hause, Highspeed ich habe mittlerweile 1000 MB wo ich nicht genau weiß, wo das eigentlich hinführen aber es fühlt sich nicht an, als wäre es 1000 MB aber da habe ich so schnell Nachrichten erreicht dass es doch die erstenh, doch. Nein, die ersten Kommentare haben das nicht erwähnt.
Doch, die ersten Kommentare haben unseren Kunst,
unseren lustigen Gag am Ende gelobt,
dass wir einfach so ab,
am besten hat mir gefallen, dass am Ende. Ja, das ist ja das
Beste eigentlich, wenn man ein Image hat, dass selbst irgendwie,
wenn die Folge komplett übersteuert ist.
Selbst so ein Schrott ist bei uns Gags. Die Leute schreiben,
also ein, wirklich ein
delikater
Humor-Spaus, den ihr da kredenzt habt. Und dieredenzt habt. Ja genau, die Filme waren nicht ernst gemacht. Das Bild war falsch rum, ja das ist echt lustig. Stimmt. Aber ich meine, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich bin da auf der Seite unserer Hörer, ich schaue mir auch Empfehlungen nie an, wenn Leute sagen, das wird dir bestimmt gefallen. Das ist allein schon eine Beleidigung. Du hast keine Ahnung, was mir gefällt. Ich habe einen sehr komplexen und sehr überraschenden Geschmack. Ich gucke jetzt nicht deine Empfehlungen auf dein YouTube-Video, sondern wieder ein Nein-Cast. Vikings, ich mag eigentlich Wikinger nicht so gerne, wie man denkt. Tatsächlich gucke ich Norseman nicht, weil es tausendmal empf. Ja, aber deswegen habe ich es dir nicht empfohlen, weil ich mir dachte, vielleicht...
Nordsman und The Wire sind Shows, die werde ich nie gucken, wurden mir zu oft empfohlen.
Nein, danke, Leute.
Deswegen möchten wir sagen, schaut auf gar keinen Fall Nordsman.
Ich meine, was für eine dumme Idee, eine Wikinger-Serie, die eine Comedy ist, lächerlich.
Also wer das anschaut, ist mir gescheuert.
Wikinger waren ernste Menschen.
Die waren ernst und kräftig und hatten weirde Götter mit einem Hammer und so gehört sich das auch. Und da macht man keinen Spaß. Das verulgt man nicht. Da wird ja nicht jetzt irgendwie so eine halbgare Pointe daraus gedrungen irgendwie. Wie zum Beispiel? Dass der eine halt ein bisschen sensibel ist und halt ein Feedback-Gespräch nach so einem Raid haben möchte, nach so einem Feldzug.
Also falls ihr Vorschläge habt, was ihr beim nächsten Mal anders machen könnt.
Nee, das ist albern.
Das ist einfach, das gehört sich auch nicht, das macht man nicht.
Nee.
Da macht man keine Witze durch.
Über Wikinger macht man keine Witze. Also Norris man bitte auf gar keinen Fall gucken.
Nee.
Ich bin sehr anfällig, die ich für Vorschläge aller Art, die ausnahmisch herangetragen werden.
Vor allem habe ich jetzt gemacht, wenn es um mein Äusseres geht.
Wenn jemand mir sagt,
prühe das doch mal aus,
prühe ich es aus.
Trag doch mal sowas.
Es dauert genau zwei Minuten und ich habe es.
Wie wäre es mit einer Halskette?
Probier mal aus.
Von dir weiß ich nicht, habe ich das gesagt.
Aber meine Frisurin hat gesagt,
Stefan, Locken würden dir auch gut stehen. Und das war der Moment, wo ich gesagt habe, okay, ich habe erst mal reagiert, ja, okay, ja, also, stand so im Raume, weil ich wusste, drei verschiedene Emotionen, ja, okay, ja, ja, was, wie soll das? Also hör auf, fick du, Locken würden dir stehen. Wenn ihr nicht wisst, wie ihr reagieren sollt, reagiert einfach alles. Einfach alle Reaktionen kurz hintereinander. Das Richtige wird schon dabei sein. Ja, er fängt an mit Lachen. Wie, ach so, nee. Was hast du gesagt? Du bist Locke. Jedenfalls habe ich dann gesagt, also habe ich nicht genau verstanden, wie ich es me. Dann hat es mir nochmal angesprochen, nochmal angesprochen, dann wurde es mir jemand empfohlen. Dann habe ich gesagt, komm, wenn du mir Locken machen willst, machen wir Locken. So, und dann habe ich jetzt, wie du siehst, Locken. Ja. Man sitzt dann da tatsächlich und es ist im Prinzip, ich sage es nicht genau, also auf Englisch Perms, man kriegt Permanent Curls, klingt ganz okay. Auf Deutsch ist die Dauerwelle, was ich nicht so gern sage, aber im Kern ist es eine Dauerwelle. Dauerwelle ist, das ist einfach, es ist besetzt durch die 80s und Hausfrauen mit einer Dauerwelle, es ist ein bisschen besetzt. Jedenfalls habe ich eben keine Dauerwelle bekommen. Man sitzt dann da zwei Stunden, kriegt dann so eine scharf ätzende Flüssigkeit in die Haare. Ich hatte natürlich pinke Lockenwickler. Natürlich, klar, weil die gibt es in der Farbe, da kriegt man pinke Lockenwickler reingedreht, dann ist erst mal die Frage, welche Größe denn genau, weil je nachdem wie klein die sind, desto krasser sind die Locken. Ja, mhm. So, ich habe dann relativ grosse Lockenwickler bekommen, pinke, grosse Lockenwickler hatte ich dann in meinem Kopf, dann kriegt man so mit Watte wie so ein Stirnband um, damit diese scharfe, ätzende Flüssigkeit, die man bekommt, die die Haut außen aufbricht, damit die die Lockenform annehmen, nicht dein Stirnchen berühren, kriegst du dann so Wattebausch um dich herum, dann kommt diese Lockenflüssigkeit rein, dann muss es dann lange einwirken, damit diese Haut aufbohren wird und dann kommt eine andere Flüssigkeit drüber, die ist dann wieder versiegelt in der neuen Lockenform. Dann wird es ausgewaschen und im Kern hat man dann schon Locken. Macht die Haare nicht so kaputt, wie zum Beispiel sowas, habe ich mir sagen lassen, wie so eine Tönung oder sowas, aber ist auch nicht so geil für die Haare. Trotzdem, mal ausprobiert, wächst da schnell nach bei mir, dachte ich. Und wie lange hält das? Das hält jetzt schon so zwei Monate wahrscheinlich. Ach krass. Ja. Aber die verlieren sich da irgendwann dann wieder. Wächst halt raus ein bisschen, weil man ach so, die lösen sich nie wieder aus, sondern es wird dann rausgewachsen. Ja, ich glaube, meine Haare wachsen schneller, als dass die Locken sich rausballern. Ich habe im Gegenteil dazu mir einmal die Haare glätten lassen. Ja. Und da war ich dann auch beim Friseur und dann hieß es sich immer gerne die Haare glätten lassen. Und dann dauert es ewig, also wirklich ewig, Stunden. Und dann habe ich auch gefragt, wie lange hält das denn? Ja, so bis heute Abend. Was? Ich meine, es hat gereicht, weil es für einen Dreh war oder für ein Fotoshooting, um genauer zu sein. Also als Gag mal ich mit glatten Haaren. Es sieht auch sehr lustig aus, aber da dachte ich mir auch so, also ihr bietet so einen Service an, dass man die Haare glätten kann und es ist halt dann danach direkt wieder weg. Ich war ja heilfroh, dass es danach wieder weg ist, weil es halt nur für einen Gag für ein Foto sein sollte, danach wieder normal. So bis heute Abend ist echt eine Ansage. Ja, weil ich auch denke, so heute Abend ist Prom Night und so während der Prom Night lösen die sich wieder auf und werden wieder so kringelig. Weil man merkt, dass man auch, wenn man sich verkleidet, doch noch der Alt ist. Ja, ausser man ballert sich Dauerwellen schön auf dem Perms rein, auf dem Kopf. Ja, jetzt habe ich einen Locken tatsächlich. Sehr cool. Es ist okay. Ich finde Ich finde es gut. Ich finde es gut. Ich meine, du bist Podcaster und Autor, also es ist nicht so, wie es aussieht. Beides sagt, ich will nicht gesehen werden. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ja, und dann habe ich jetzt tatsächlich auch, musste ich jetzt auch das stylen mit Locken lernen. Und ich habe dich vergessen zu fragen, aber ich habe viele Leute im Umfeld mit Locken gefragt, wie es läuft, und dann habe ich jetzt so Curly, Curly-Creme. Das ist alles ein bisschen weiblicher, habe ich das Gefühl, so die Wörter um Curly-Sero. Du kennst dich jetzt schon besser mit Locken aus als ich. Du machst Curly-Creme rein und dann fönst du es. Kannst du überföhnen. Du machst gar nichts? Ich mache gar nichts. Nein, die sind einfach so, wie du die Räder sind. Je weniger man macht, desto mehr müssen sich die Haare... Du hast schon ein bisschen Produkt in den Haaren. Doch, sehe ich doch.
Nein, vielleicht von gestern vom Dreh noch, das kann sein.
Aber nicht von mir, aber ich glaube ja, je weniger man macht, desto mehr müssen sich die Haare selber am Riemen reissen und sagen, scheiße, wir müssen sich selber auf die Reine... Woher kommt am Riemen reissen?
Jetzt reisse ich immer am Riemen.
Naja, Riemen kann ja alles sein.
Heisse ich so am Riemen von jemandem mitreissen, also selbst wenn man stark verwundet ist? Ich bin immer im Ersten Weltkrieg noch, wegen im Westen nichts Neues. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Hat der immer eine Fortsetzung geschrieben? Im Westen ein bisschen was Neues? Aber da wird jetzt ein Film gedreht, ne? Mit Daniel Brühl. Ja, Daniel Brühl verfilmt im Westen nichts Neues und ich hätte so Bock da mitzuspielen. Ja, ich auch.
Und auch nicht als irgendwie tragende Rolle oder so. Ich würde da gerne einfach auftauchen, einfach mal irgendwie um in Erster-Weltkriegs-Uniform da irgendwie nüchtern. Nee, wir würden uns als Rahmen zurauben. Daniel, also wir würden uns anbieten, Flotin und ich, manche kennen uns in Deutschland, weil wir Podcaster sind. Was natürlich den Film nicht hilft, den wirksam unterstützen würde. Ach so, ja. Weil, sind wir mal ehrlich, Historienfilme, Erster Weltkrieg ...
Ihr braucht viele Leute, die im Frontgraben hocken und jung sind. Im Hintergrund Unschärfe? Ja, und die sind ja auch jünger. Also die sind ja viele Soldaten, gerade im Ersten Weltkrieg, gerade später hat man viele jüngere Leute hingeschickt und so, weil es nicht so gut lief. Kennt man ja aus der Geschichte. Also wir beide würden uns anbieten, wir sind unter 30, jetzt nicht unbedingt gesichtsbekannt, ich zumindest nicht, wir haben ein bisschen mehr, aber wir würden ja vorher in der Podcast-Folge darüber reden, dass wir gut gemacht haben. Ja, vielleicht kann ja Stefan dafür irgendwie so das Gesicht weckerissen werden, dass da irgendwie so eine Granate einschlägt und seinen Kopf weckerissen wird oder irgendwie sowas in der Ecke.
Kostüme würden wir uns selber besorgen. Ja, vielleicht kann ja Stefan dafür irgendwie so das Gesicht weckerissen werden, dass da irgendwie so eine Granate einschlägt und seinen Kopf weckerissen wird oder irgendwie sowas in der Ecke.
Kostüme würden wir uns selber besorgen. Also das ist unser Angebot, ihr müsst uns nicht also irgendwie verkleiden. Wir kennen da gute Kostümverleiher. Er trägt halt eine Designerbrille und hat jetzt halt einen sehr extravaganten Haarstil.
Vielleicht könnte man da was machen, dass er halt irgendwie so ein Holzbrett ins Gesicht geschlagen bekommt von einem Franzosen.
Oder halt irgendwie so ein Bajonett, dass sich jemand mit dem Bajonett ins Gesicht sticht oder irgendwie sowas, also jetzt nur als Angebot. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, weil ich habe das Locken irgendwie, das sieht aus wie jemand aus dem Ersten Bergkrieg. Ja, aber zurück zu den Rollen. Wenn du vielleicht in Flammen stehst oder so, dass man dann nicht genau... Ja, auch das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, ob das sein muss.
Aber jedenfalls, wir sind da offen, mit auf die Flammengeschichte, sind wir relativ offen, irgendwie mitzumachen. Und wir würden uns auf einander freuen. Wir werden beide, würden wir unbezahlt mitmachen und im Schützengraben sitzen. Natürlich, klar, wenn hier und da noch eine Zeile gesagt werden muss, gerne, kein Problem, aber muss auch nicht sein. Und ja, also, Herr Brühl würde uns freuen, wenn Sie auf dem postalischen Weg, Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen, zentrale at podcast-ufo.fail, schreiben Sie uns eine Nachricht und wir melden uns dann, wir würden uns dann melden, also vielen Dank. Also sehr schnell, extrem unangenehm schnell. Lässt du manchmal Mails länger im Postfach, weil du Angst hast, sofort zu antworten? Ja, absolut. Auch tatsächlich irgendwie so Twitter-Nachrichten oder so. Ich krieg die halt ping und denk mir, ich kann da jetzt nicht sofort drauf antworten. Nee, ich bin vor dem Willen, ich kann nicht direkt antworten. Was denkt denn die Welt von mir, wenn ich jetzt sofort antworte? Mach ich auch manchmal nicht. Ich lese eure Nachrichten. Deswegen eigentlich immer, dass es da noch keinen Messenger gibt, der dieses Feature hat, dass du eine Nachricht schreibst und dann so in einer Stunde senden. Mega. Wäre mega gut. Also bei Twitter gibt es ja den geschedulten Tweet, aber bei DMs, glaube ich, geht das nicht. Und dann müsste man aber noch bei dem anderen das Feature einbauen. Zeig mir doch schon mal die Nachrichten an, die der andere noch in der Pipeline hat, damit ich jetzt schon mal darauf reagieren kann. Dass man dieses ganze soziale Tango einfach mal so skippt mit so einer Bezahlfunktion. Ja, wenn ihr unsere App nämlich kauft, also die Bezahlfunktion, wenn ihr Messenger Plus kauft, dann könnt ihr die Nachrichten sehen, die euer Partner in der Pipeline hat. Und vor allem für 1000 Euro im Monat seht ihr die Entwürfe des anderen. Alles, was er schreibt und dann noch mal gelöscht hat, seht ihr auch. Ihr seht live, wie er schreibt. Ja, ihr seht live, wie er schreibt. Und währenddessen geht die Kamera an. Während er schreibt. Ja, das ist dann die Voyeurism. 5000 Euro im Monat. Wir werden sowas von reich. Blutin, es hat mir wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, wir haben... Uiuiuiuiui!
Ich war so umgefallen.
Wir haben eine Woche vor uns, wir werden viel erleben und freuen uns natürlich auch, euch nächste Woche wieder begrüssen zu dürfen.
Teilhaben zu das in unserem fantastischen Drehleben.
Bald haben wir wieder andere Themen drauf, wir freuen uns, mit euch zu quatschen.
Haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche, bis dann, wir heben ab, macht's gut!